You
Lol
Hey, wait say something. Oh
Oh
You're not in here, why isn't it working? What if I unplugged this sometimes sometimes my goal XLR like transfers stuff really weirdly
Yeah, like you're yeah, you're my Tulpa nobody can hear
I'm sorry, you guys can't hear all the funny stuff that trinket is saying to me
Sometimes my goal XLR were transfer
stuff
Let me see. I just have to click through a bunch of crap and hope that it works
Start singing or something
Why I want it it doesn't want to pick that up hold on maybe if I go to properties
That was really good though, it was really good too, they'll never know oh
What if I do say something
Why doesn't it want to pick up on what?
Maybe that'll be a bummer
Just from Firefox. Oh, there it is there they go. Yeah, there you are. Okay. Let me turn you down a bit
PoE fixed
Harlots she's here
Curse collab never curse couldn't be us. We're so lucky everything works out for us
Only members can hear her voice. I would be interesting. She was spitting bars. You guys missed out
Let me pull up the smash or pass window
hell yeah, uh
Trinket is currently cooking up a mup itself
I am are you giving yourself a Scooby-Doo caller?
That's always been in the plans
Up always the jam. I love it
Because Scooby-Doo is well, he's not my first choice husband, but he's definitely like
on the list of
Cartoon characters that would be an automatic smash for me. Yeah
Yeah
But like if I take Scooby I have to take the rest of the the mystery game you understand I understand
because like
Actually, I was talking about this on Sunday because I've been on a real Omegaverse kick lately. Mm-hmm
And so I yeah, I sent me some of my diverse stuff
Because I've been recommended to it by in budding friendship, but I'm really enjoying it, but
In my mind, right? Mm-hmm in my mind
There is like this the Scooby-Doo game, right?
Chaggy is very much an alpha
And so and so is
Okay
Fred is a very beta male. Okay, but he's got Omega tendencies. All right
Daphne is a straight-up
Beta with Omega tendencies, but she's more like badass. All right, that's beta and then
Velma is nothing but pure Omega energy
Like Velma's been with everybody on the crew. Velma's just like the comfort creature in the mystery ink machine
I never would have thought of this like
If the gang or Omegaverse, that's you know
That's just that's just that's just how it goes. That's just how it be. I don't think I'm wrong. I
Think I'm more right than anything honestly. Yeah, Trinket's getting me into Omegaverse stuff. So blame her for anything
Like if madam she be starts calling you guys submissive and readable some of you might be Omega's
Well, it looks like I have some inappropriate stuff on my screen, but I promise I don't
You know
The whole stream is gonna be inappropriate, but you know pop offs pop off singular window. That's blurred pop off
It's from the the sucker punch stream, I know I was there
Yes, I know you were there I
Really like suck a sucker punch with all you guys. It was really good. Did you like it?
I mean, I was a little confused, but I see where it's going for yeah
Like it's um, it's like American McGee's Alice in Wonderland. Yeah
But like a little more a little more nuance. Mm-hmm
Like it's a it's a fantasy within a fantasy
Within a real situation that she's just dissociating the whole time with precisely
It's very oops, it's very
Frick did I accidentally smash the wooden version
So I'm so glad that that manlet didn't say her at the very oh, yeah
Anything that he wanted from the situation. Yeah Oscar Oscar Isaac got what was coming from blue
And then like and then he was a snitch at the very end. I know it was ridiculous
He's oh, he's so frustrating, but pretty
Like that the girls actually died that the orderlies kill them
I think the order that's what I was thinking about as I was falling asleep
after stream, I'm like
Because every time I watch the movie I like think of other
things like different like parallels and stuff and I'm like cuz
Doc the doctor never said that two other patients died. She just said she started a fire
And got let one escape some but I'm I still think that they died a hundred percent
You know, you know what could have happened because like and like insane
Asylums were so bad during the time period that I'm presuming this yeah
It looks like it was like the 50s or 60s or something like they might have died due to treatment
With their death by just giving it to an orderly because the orderlies would take patients away. Yeah
That's a good. That's a very
Good observe
Observation hundred percent. Sorry. I'm half asleep so I can barely form words
That's okay. I've got more than double words. I
Didn't do like the New York Times wordal bullshit, but like I'll I'll make up some I'll make up some nouns and some adjectives for you
A E I O U Y
Okay, W X nice
Fabulous
Maybe maybe is maybe a cue the maybe a cue a rare cue in there a rare cue
I'm barely following
All right
How are you going with your Muppet version we might we might transform to Muppets I
Guess I just got to do the one thing for the hair and then
Let's see
All I got to do is do my little pinkies little pinkies little pinkie poos
Yeah, my little pinkie poos it it makes it makes the look. I'm very fashionable
You always have to have a bit of pop, you know, I agree
Pull up my food you took
So I can just have my Muppet self next to me
Because there there is a Muppet, but it's of the monkey. Oh
Yeah, I'm Toma like how you call her the monkey
Ignore the random browser source on my screen
There we are
Wait, I'll have to go into
Flip it horizontally, I do have to flip it horizontally
Or we swap places because of the way that I
Looks like we're gonna have a great conversation
It's like my mic just constantly on in this call. What the hell I
Mean, there's a little bit of
Was it my fucking AC
But that's not that's not bad. I kind of like it. It's a nice background
I appreciate that everyone likes my background noise. I
Mean, it's it's like the white noise
It's like when you're sitting out on a on a hot porch and you're listening to the summer rain
And you get that nice rain smell and you just
And you just snored it
Yeah, you you snort the rain you snort the rain smell
Absolutely. Oh my god. All right. I have my little mini me next to me and now she talks when she's supposed to
Hell yeah, hell yeah, hell yeah
I'm almost done
Take your time
I'm just staring at this ugly wooden ball
He is the world
I
Hate him
Just he's so ugly. Why did they make him made out of wood? They had they had metal
Why is his top made out of wood? I don't know. I feel like they could have also put that part on the bottom
They could have
Actually when they did it for a wool tour but looks even crazier, so he looks better than wool tour at least
Splinters very true. I'd like to talk with Muppet she be after stream about what?
About what?
You have with this Muppet. Yeah, what business do you have with this Muppet?
You want to throw it at a wall that hurts that hurts me deeply
I mean, there is that trend where people like buy Fumos, right and they just beat them and then they yeah
Kind of soak them in milk and throw them at a wall
Of course, I don't think your demographic wants to soak them in milk. Yeah, probably not milk, but something probably
Similar to that
Wait, why did they why did they put Fumos and milk? I
Don't
What's the you know, I I couldn't tell you why anybody does anything except you know for the laughs
Yeah, just for the laughs for some twisted laughs
Just for just for a little hee-hee hoo-hoo ha ha, you know
It's a little tee-hee's a little tee-hee hee-hee's. I'm speaking of which I need a tweet hee-hee hee-hee hee's
Hee-hee hee-hee
Hee-hee hee-hee hee-hee hee-hee
I love the out-of-pocket
thumbnail
My manager made for me. I
Also like it. It's very different. I wasn't even gonna bother covering it up
And then it's been up for a while and hasn't gotten demonetized. So it's fun
Well, that's because ass and boobs is different you can have ass because no boobs butts are funny
No, yeah, because I just have a front butt on my chest
Yeah, you do but there's also like the risk of having like that female presenting nipple. I
Couldn't have a female presenting nipple on my butt. She maybe
Like a raised mole like a pimple like a butt pimple. Oh gross. No, but no butt pimples here. Please. No, thank you
All right
Tweeted I
Forgot to tag you
That's okay. I'll retweet it. I'll find it
I am a mess
That's okay. You're running on what an hour of sleep essentially not even more like ten minutes
That's a power nap. That's like the ten minute power hour, but you know a little bit shorter than a ten minute power hour now
RIP original game grumps. I know right
Not the pimples
Amy would love that. Yeah, cuz well though. Yeah, we like to pop zits, but I don't want one on my butt
Oh, yeah, no, that's awful, but it's a popping videos are very nice
I love watching pimple popping videos
It's just like I could sit there for hours and just get sucked into a rabbit hole of just pimple popping videos
right
Yeah, do you ever just like enjoy?
Looking at it like the ear wax removal ones as well
I I watched it ear wax removal one the other way, but for some odd reason that
Actually grosses me out a little bit, but like but which is weird cuz like I like to watch like the really like big
cyst pops like the like
Dr. Pimple Popper. Yeah, like the really gross one. So I don't know why ear wax just like
Doesn't do it for me, but I watched your brain. Yeah, maybe yeah, maybe cuz it's yeah, it's not something
It's not like being extract. Well, it is being extracted. It's not being like
Pushed I don't know how to explain it. It's the act
It's the act of unless it's um, I did watch one in this person
Just like twirled a little tool in their ear and just like yoinked it out and I was like whoa
That's really cool. I wish I could get my ears professionally cleaned
You can if you get like one of those
Watery things like a water pig you could just point it at your ear and you can irrigate your ear. Oh
Soffeting drops boom. I feel like I would just give myself an ear infection just
Somehow cuz I'm sometimes prone to those I would definitely just like end up giving myself an ear infection
Honestly, I always get ear infections and I always get like sore throats at the beginning of the year
No, honestly every new years. I'm like, this is the year
I'm gonna ask the ask the dentist to take my tonsils out. Oh, I've asked them
They said told me no cuz I have like enlarged tonsils. They're like, you know bigger tonsils than normal
I'm like great yoink them out. I'm tired of them
Cuz they're just like I don't know. I don't like open my mouth and I'm just like
Not that they're noticeable, but like whatever I poke around in my mouth a lot. It sounds weird. I don't know
You ever you ever get one of those like tonsil stones
Yes, I hate them. That's yeah
You're always like you're always just trying to draw it up and then like it feels like you're gagging. Yeah
It's so gross, it's I hate them they smell like death smells like a dead grandma
And no matter how much you brush your teeth your breath never gets any better when you have one
Yeah, that's why sometimes I'll just check make sure
Because my my tonsils are bigger sometimes I'll like get one and I'm like, ah
No, that's why I'm just like just let me let me just like laser them off
So I don't ever have to get tonsil stones ever again. Oh
I forgot I was gonna say
Doesn't matter
I'm EP second
So I'm just like what do I talk about next
The infinity tonsil stones gross. Oh
Oh
That's like. Oh god, it's tonsil stones all the way down like
But it could be worse it could be worse it could be kidney stones. That's true kidney stones are horrible. I've heard I
Have never had one. They're probably all resting inside me like hidden diamonds
No, then you would be be peeing just pure fire
Constantly
But like also I feel like you could make jewelry if you were just an infinite kidney stone source
It's more like from what I've heard it's more of like a sandy
Granule rather than like a stone stone
Yeah, but what if you like sand it and smooth it like you get like just like a little roller
Yeah, yeah
Make a little kidney stone ring and then be like I want you to have this
My piss buddy, my buddy and it's like this is a part of me that I'm giving to you. We are pistars and arms
Yep, yep
Truly truly that's how that's how we roll in this household. Hmm. I
Had tonsils taking out cuz constant ear infections. Oh, that's the word. That's the worst
That's why I wanted to get the cuz I also um, I
Have because of inflammation in my neck for my arthritis
I'm one of my eustachian tubes are always kind of like sort of blocked and I was hoping if I got my tonsil removed
It would like help with that because I'm just like I feel it
I'm sometimes like deaf in my right ear because I'm like what?
Why I
Can't hear what you're saying. It's like the weirdest feeling having your ear blocked
Hi Rena, all right, I hope my art program unfreezes itself soon so I can finish saving this magnificent muppet that I've drawn
It is quite gorgeous. You guys are not ready
Let me go back in to share my no not share my screen. Oh wait you ended it. Oh
I'm sorry. I guess. No, you're fine. You're fine. Okay
I wanted to look at where you were at
Oh, I finished it. You think trinket could be turned up a little bit more. I can do that for you. Whoo
Someone thrown her that horn thing that people used to hear better
It happens because I'm 56. That's correct. Did you know that wax candles don't work?
Like what do you mean?
Like there's like this old wives tale where if you put like some foil and a candle in your ear. Oh
Yeah, ear candling. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
It doesn't do anything
Have you tried it?
No, I did research on it. I
Swear I've done it before when I was a kid and it worked. I don't know. I kind of just been tripping as a child
I mean, I'm totally delusional as children. Yeah
Maybe but like I feel like I feel like
Maybe
Yes, I forget there is the science behind it
It's the science behind it and there's it's a big scam. It's the paper cone works not wax
Oh, maybe I was the paper cone that I had. Hello. Hello. Welcome in
Time candles or wax play
Oh, wait, nope. Oh, the monkey's here. No
I was trying to do the car. Monkey jumpscare monkey monkey Muppet jumpscare. Whoops
Hold on. I got I got you. I got you. I'm just waiting with excitement
It's the debut everyone's been waiting for
Wait
Wait, hold up. Hold on. Hold on. Wait
Wait, I'm fukie. Fukie hard. Hold on. I'm fukieing so hard right now. I'm fukieing my shibidi
so hard
Okay, okay, okay, okay
Okay, I think I think we got it. Yeah, blam
Oh
There she is
She's so cute
There we go
I can't believe it. I'm gonna flip you
um
Hold on a moment
30 minutes not bad. Yeah, yeah, you did that in uh, honestly a quick amount of time
Poy fuked
Play fuked play fuked and now
I will remove my
Excuse me to deform
Farewell
I may make you a little bit
But I think I'm smaller than you you are so I'm gonna I thought as much
I'm just a little just a little we look so great
Just a bunch of muppets
In your little hands, where's your wait, where's your other hand? It's it's it's resting. I'm tired
It's resting
Ah
My hand's not up. I'm polite. I have my hands in a polite position because I'm a guest here
Because it looks like you have two hands up your butt
I might
This is this is muppet time with uh trinket and sheafy
We're gonna we're gonna smash and pass some balls. Yeah, okay. We already I think we already passed on this one, didn't we?
Yeah, we passed on we passed on these wooden balls. Yeah
The splinters aren't worth it. No, no, thank you. I'm good with that
Never saw this episode of the muppets while you're about to
Be the best episode you've ever seen
Uh execute these are eggs
How to eat them um
I could I could see them being useful though
You know like you could be into obvi position. I was thinking that I'm not into that but I get it
Because like I've I've read I've read some I've read some mangoes in my in my history
and
you know
Sometimes sometimes
Sometimes you're just introduced a little too early to some things and they're just with you for life
That's very accurate. I agree with that statement
So like honestly, it's a it's a smash and eat for these. It's a smash and eat
I it's it's just a pass and eat for me
Do you think do you think the body has the ability to boil eggs if you like put them in there though?
I don't know let's try with the chicken egg and I'll get back to you
It's okay
Oh my goodness body well actually
No, because what's the body the body's?
basal temperature
Is like 97. I I bet
How how much the boiling?
Rate for water isn't like 110 or something Fahrenheit. So what you're telling me is we need to find a sick person
Have them put the eggs up there
And then have the lady eggs and then you could have like
A sentry style boiled egg from another woman. That's perfect
So 100 degrees Celsius. Yeah, so yeah, it's essentially what we do for like 10 to 12 minutes do that
Yeah, this is an experiment that I think should actually happen
It would be like a tea egg
Yeah, like a little quail egg
Tuck it up your butthole
If any of you guys get sick with the fever, I need you to do this. Uh, this is uh
This is a question. This is a request for you
It takes 300 700 slaps to cook a whole chicken
What?
I I mean, I guess if you just keep slapping it
I feel like that would have to be 700 slaps at all at once. Wouldn't it?
No, no, no like seven like it the heat would build up probably maybe
If I if I slap my ass 700 times
You're that
Can't be helped you're cooked at that point. I'm cooked. Yeah, I'm cooked so cooked. All right executor
He could be cuter. He could be cuter eggs that could be cuter, you know
But I like his dopey face
He's got three of them. I mean I give him a smooch, but I move on
Yeah
Really? I definitely kiss like one of the faces. Yeah, maybe not one in the back
He looks like a kisser
I gave him a little smooch and I feel like he would get like bashful like uh like bashful from um
the
I almost said the wizard of Oz uh snow white
Okay, but the apple-throwing trees in the wizard of Oz might might hit for some people, you know
They definitely might definitely hit people. That's that's that's totally true
Oh my gosh, I haven't seen the wizard of Oz in such a long time
Uh, what about the tall boy version?
Oh, that's a smash
Why?
I mean
He's like six one
I almost spit out my tea
How tall is the executor elolan version he's seven feet tall he's seven throat goat
Five was a dude then yes
I mean are you a tree hugger trinket?
I mean tree humper in nature in my nature. That's a good point. It's in my nature. That's a good point
I'm gonna pass
I'm gonna smash
um
Cubone I would just want to take care of this little cute baby. That's it. I mean he is an orphan
Yeah, I'd be a good mom
You would I think I I I'd you know treat him right
Make sure he's not too traumatized by his mother's death and make him work stop wearing his mom's skull
I you can just keep it, but like I don't want to wear it. That's that's not really good
you know
That's not a good healthy. No, it's not healthy
But you know
I have this theory about cubone. Uh-huh
I think cubones like once they get over the loss of their mother become kengis kongs
Oh, yeah
I feel like
In a distant dream. We've had this conversation before
Or maybe I with a with a particular cat. I'm not sure
um
All right, so what would you do? I kind of want to eat it at the same time
Is it messed up that I kind of want to cook it in its mom's skulls a little bowl?
I mean we do the same thing with bread bowls. Exactly
So like I don't see anything wrong with it. All right. Okay. I feel a little bit better about that now
It's kind of like the same sort of principle. Do you feel bad when you have scrambled eggs and chicken?
Oh, that's a good point
I can't believe eggs are just chicken periods
I think about that often
It's kind of messed up sometimes you can get lucky with a double yoker. That's true
That chicken would have had twins
Imagine if women's eggs were that big when we had our periods
God that would fucking suck. I would hate my life even more than I already do getting a period. Oh my god
But what if it came out so easily like an egg like once a month like bomb actually that would be nice
Because if it was if I just had to lay an egg once a month and that was all I had to do
Instead of being pained for eight days and just bleed heavily then um
Yeah, I'd rather lay an egg
And then you can eat it, right?
Yeah, absolutely like almost like when pregnant women eat the prosenta. It's probably has like nutritional properties just like normal eggs
Honestly, it would probably open up a new market
And like there would be so less like human hunger like just get yourself a woman to lay you an egg. Yeah
I feel and then yeah, the whole like egg industry
Would be a very different place guys. I think we should make this happen
Honestly, how do we get women to start laying eggs?
Honestly new work class
But then again like do they well
Does the egg stay inside when when it's fertilized?
Oh, that's a good point
Hmm, huh. Hmm. You have to workshop that. Yeah, okay. I'm gonna pass. Uh, Marowak
I'm good. I'm good. It's a pass for me. Okay
This one's kind of cool looking but it's just repainted and made skinny
Basically, it's slim though. Yeah, I'm Marowak but cooler
Burn the work mom
Yeah, yeah, he's like a little like scene kid
Going through her golf girl phase before she becomes a mom
Hitman Lee
Man's got legs and arms no mouth though. Yeah
What no mouth don't do it's kind of disappointing
I mean you could still sit on the face. It'd just be more like a mutual rub
You could use the you could use the legs as a grinder
You could and maybe the face as a grinder
He's also got fingers. That's a good point. I don't know. I just don't feel
I'm not feeling anything with this, you know
Yeah, there's there's not enough defining features. Yeah
He's kind of like and he's kind of like a faceless man from a hentai. Yeah
I
Like he just needs like protagonist hair
Could be like the self-insert and then you're golden
For what he is
But then I would if he looked more like the the faceless protagonist because the faceless protagonist
Always has a mouth and like long hair covering their eyes if it was reversed
I would I would then I would say yes
But this is not the case so
Pass he's a pass. Uh hitman chan. Hitman chance of smash. Yeah
Yeah, very cute. I like their outfit. She got a little skirt going
I bet I bet the I bet the third leg has a little boxing glove at the end
Bro I need a drink for this
Hahaha
I always thought hitman chan was a girl
Because it's just chan and she's wearing a dress
It could be a girl or a boy. Oh, okay. I don't know. I just always saw it like that
Uh, I'm just feel like I'd be kind of scared because I feel like they'll be very
Fisting and if you're saying there's a little glove at the end of that then I'm even more terrified
I mean, it's just it's just punching up at the inside door
Yeah, my inside door just got really scared and quivered in fear
They're 100 male. Okay, then I'm
Riona. Yeah for yeah a little riona
But I would rather like an actual fist than a glove for that
You know
I I would hate to think that like it has a little hand at the end of its third leg though
I'd hate to think that
passing
Yeah, they've always been cute to me. I'm a smash hitman champ. You're gonna have okay understandable. Um look at tongue
Oh, that
The conversation doesn't need to be I know it's it's a no-brainer to be honest with you
smash
The tongue king the gluck look five thousands
Throat goat throat goat, you know, probably no gag reflex because he swallows just about anything you give him precisely
A call him Kirby the way he swallows
Coughing
That's a pass
I like the pause we both had we're just like
Like if I were a guy
And I had like an air purifier
Maybe use the holes for something
Yeah
Tuck a little honestly by default. No, that's a pass. Yeah, that's that's I feel like I would just die
Like I something would happen and then same with wheezing
I mean unless it's like that dank's uh coming out of there. No
Yeah, like I just feel like it just smells like farts or it's gonna kill me so
Yeah
Like if he wasn't like an abuser and you could burn that that that magic leaf in him probably
Now this one just looks like a gentleman who's wanting to pay for a good time
Bring me your finest
courtesans
Like he you just see him on the street. He's got a little he's got his top hats
You give him a little cane and he's like, excuse me, madam. How much for you think I've got about
20 dimma dome dollars
I have about 20 pounds to pound your life away if you'll have me of course
um
I'll pass but I would I would I would entertain him for a bit, but then I wouldn't let him hit
Honestly, if he spoke to me like the high roller from sucker punch
Just like sucker punch sucker punch high roller have me like yeah, john ham
Cancel man john ham
Yeah, what about this rocky unicorn?
Uh, you know, I bet is very right horny
I mean, I mean, there's there's there's three different ways to mount it
Yeah, you have a lot of ridges
to ride
So like, you know, it's for it's for you and the besties
Yeah, that's definitely like a group
activity, um
But like what if you're alone and it tries to sit on you or like mount you I think I would just die
No, he's a he's a rock. He's a rock monster. No. Yeah, I'm gonna pass because like at some point
He's gonna ask why I'm not giving
And I want to be able to provide that's you know, what a good partner does, you know balance
Give and take I mean you'd have to knock him on his back and like strand him like a turtle
I feel like yeah, and I don't even think he could be on his back right like normally
You'd have to do like sideways because his little back horn
Yeah, he'd definitely freak out. Yeah, I feel like he would just not have a great time. We're just not compatible
No, no, he's too big. We're too squishy. We're muppets. We're muppets
Uh ride on
It's kind of more doable. Yeah. Hello. It's called ride on. Why would I not ride on on the ride on?
He's he's also got that physique like a dad bod
You know, I like me. I like me a dad bod
You know what he feels like he could be the male version of a kengis kong
I always thought that I always thought he was the male version of it because they look
Precisely the same minus the pouch in the color scheme
Right and there's like it's almost like uh the males are smaller because the kengis kongs are quite large
But then again, they're probably like in the same like egg class too. So
I'll smash. What about you? I'll smash it as well. Yeah
Chancey, I'm pretty sure that horn goes around and around and around
Horn for days horn for days spit on that like a top
Um chancey
You know what? I've always been a chancey fan. Uh, she's a smash for me
I was gonna it's just like would you take her egg and pop that sucker in like who's gonna give you the egg if you're sad
So like if you're in a sexy situation with a chancey that thing's going probably up one of the holes
And it like dissolves and it's like all glittery and then you just feel better and really happy because like
That's that's what she does. She hunts you down
And gives you your her egg
I think
I think I would sit I would eat her and I think I'll sit in the cockshare for that one
Okay, because I want to see how that works out
So past it would be a sweet it would be a sweet urethane. That's what yeah, that's what and I you know, I'm I kind of want to watch
um
But it's like it's funny because I'm on the fence if there was like a maybe I would give a maybe
Like I have to be in a the right headspace
uh
Tangela tangela I can never pronounce
Tangela tanga see I can't
It's okay. It's
tangela here
Why she's a lady
She's got that beautiful hair. Yeah, what's the consistency of uh, it's little
Are they like tentacles?
Or she's like a bush
I'm gonna say they're like tentacles
Okay
And I always like imagine they're like a jelly sort of consistency. Yeah, like wishy. Yeah, because I'm like then yes
I'm a fan of tentacles
uh
People are saying vines
Are they vines? I don't know. I don't know is tank what way I know she's a plant
Hold on
Is tangela I can I'll answer this with a quick google search grass type. It goes our vines. Yeah
I mean, I don't want vines up my Muppet Muppetissie, you know, but there's but there's no leaves
So they're like perfectly smooth
Uh true
I'll give it a chance. I'll give it a chance
You'll give them a chance because you like them a lot
Uh kengish con
Smash smash just hire babysitter. Yeah and hang out
Yeah, she's got hot mom vibes hot mom. She's a single mom. She's making her she's she's making her
She's making money for her baby. Yeah, I work hard for the money like that's her
That's her. Yeah smash
Smash and then you know, I'll take responsibility. I'll help raise this child with her
You would have such a wholesome family life together. I believe
You're not the stepdad. You're the dad that stepped up. Yeah
That's such a good fucking line
Uh the mega version where the kid
is just out of the
pouch
You give that kid 20 to go to the movies
Oh, yeah, it's me and your mom. We're gonna hang out go hang out with your friends
I'm good. Don't come home for like at least three hours. Yeah, don't
possibly four if we're
We're up. We're trying new things. Um
We're playing new games. Don't worry about it kiddo. Here's some here's some pizza money
Go to the arcade
And then you're you're just you're just in the bedroom you're playing smash on switch
We just didn't want the kid to interrupt
Uh
Horses for the male gaze
However, remember that one toy
This the sucker toy does this because can horsey also suck
Yeah, because I feel like it would be like one of those little
Like a little as long vibrator toy like a rose as long as it has like an any and any option and not
Like an outie only option with just the bubbles
Because like the last thing you want to do it is blow in
Yeah
Like I wouldn't I would just it would primarily be used for down there
Or nipples or yeah or nipple. Yeah a little bit of
Muppet nipple
Felt up if you know what I mean
Oh, I get it because of the material. Yeah, you got it. I got it. I'm so smart
Um, so I will say
smash for horsey
I'm I'm also gonna have to go with smash for this one. Okay
But again, if I was a man, then I would
This would be a no brainer. That's a hole every hole's a goal if I was every hole's the goal
Even even coffings
Um
For cedra though, I feel like it wouldn't be as good
Because so many harsh edges
Too sharp. Yeah, I don't feel like I would be able to get a good grip
Well, you could definitely get a good grip
But I feel like once you were done and like you were in bed not cuttable. Yeah
You roll over that thing you're impaled
Yeah
And not like in the good way obviously sliced up on like sandpaper like scales or something
Yeah, too aggressive. I'm gonna say pass
Pass sorry cedra
Goldeen
That's a no brainer right there. That's for everybody. That's for everybody
It's got two e's for everyone
I
Ready to eat you for everyone. I mean so good they put it in twice
All right, we are fucking the goldfish smash
How see king I don't like the teeth. No, no pass
Pass down. It's a downgrade. Yeah, be careful. Be careful who you call cute in high school. They might just never glow down
I
star
I mean
I'm robbing it. Yeah
I would definitely rob this thing. Um
I'm like wondering if
You could like put little things on each of its little hands
They use it as like a multi-use toy
You definitely could
Yeah, but like it would just be
But then again, it's a fucking starfish
Like at that point you might as well just get yourself something fake and not a living creature. Yeah, exactly. That's why I'm thinking like
It's a pass. Yeah, I'm gonna pass
Sorry star you star me same thing. I'm robbing it robin robin. You're robbing it. Oh by the way if you're new here
Hello, um
Because I see some newer
newer faces
Uh trinket you want to introduce yourself?
Hello, I'm trinket. I'm your step dog or your dog-in-law. I stream on toma keys channel on twitch
And she be here. It has been my long time. Good. Good. Chum my bestie. Yeah busties busties
My sister from another mister
She's a dog and I'm a bunny. It's a very very lengthy conversation that we don't want to get into. Um, but
Uh, and I'm she be con bum. I'm your favorite to girl failure dom
um
And yeah, we're muppets right now doing smash or pass with pokemon
That's just how we are
I mean, that's just the nature of things you see a muppet. You're wondering if that muppet's gonna smash a pokemon
Or pass it or eat it because I imagine if there's a muppet pokemon
God I think wait, it's so interesting. Wait, isn't that kind of like a
Mimmy no
No, not a mimmy cute. It would be something like maybe a shuffle
Yeah, well
Or or like a bat or or what's that? What's that one doll called the one with the zipper mouth?
I know exactly which one you're thinking about
It's like a little yeah, oh my god, you're right. It would be like a little puppet
Or just shop it. Thank you. Thank you, heebie-teebie
Yeah, but that or shop it. Yeah
Yeah
Dog and bunny muppet duo doing smash or pass pokemon. It's quite the the time the an interesting timeline
Um, but yeah, I hope you stick around like comment and subscribe
I almost said Jenna marbles line. I put out new videos every Wednesday
I miss her. I miss her so much. I miss her
Not the internet for running off a very wholesome woman. I know
She was my comfort comfort youtuber and watch. I know I love nasty boy kermit
Oh, and I want to go back and like watch some of her old videos after this
I'll save
All right, mr. Mime
Okay, so I have very complex emotions about mr. Mime. Please elaborate
Okay, so there's a comic that's on tumblr where they talk about the logistics of eating mr. Mime
And that has been with me for years
Look, why do I feel like I've heard this before? Oh, yeah, ash's dad is the
also the
Also ash's dad. Yeah, I mean
I don't mind sharing with ash's mom because she's she herself seems like a bit of a freak who would share mr. Mime
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm
And also he is a definite smash
Um, I'm good
I feel like I feel like his fingers would be like sticky
I just think of mr. Mime from the live action pokemon movie and he was terrifying
I don't I don't I'm not I'm not envisioning real life pokemon
I'm envisioning cute 2d once because we're too. I know 2d muppet girls. I'm just I'm just
I'm just uh traumatized from live action mr. Mime
And also uh like clefable or clefairy, whichever one it was. No, it was jigglypuff. Those things were freaking terrifying for that movie
Everything in that movie was freaking terrifying. It really was uh clowns sometimes scare me as well. So
Aw
Not even actually it's like they
They're unnerving. I just think of john wane gasey
Oh
I feel like I feel like mr. Mime would gasey some
Some in uh innocence. So
Man
I'm not I'm not that caught up on my true crime. I wish I knew more about I never
Please don't
It's bad
Fair enough. Um, I'm gonna pass
Like what's your opinion on people who actually have it for the new it clown and not the old it clown
That's so funny to me because like I
I've seen it like I like understand it
Again, sometimes when I'm really scared of something
I'll sexualize it. So I'm just like I'm gonna trick myself into being horny for it
And so I did do that with pennywise at some point and so now I'm not scared of pennywise
That's fair, but I mean, how could you not look at that clown and think damn that head that head is totally okoteer
I could sell ad space on that clown's head
Make a million dollars
I'm just terrifying
Innocent children. They're just like, what's this weird ad placement on this head? Now. I want to buy a box of pop-tarts crazy
Um, yeah, joes. Where where's the address? Oh, there it is. It's right underneath the advertisement
Oh
Seven head um
Okay, what about the the galar version? I'm robbing it
I mean, he looks so fashionable. Look at that drip. He's iced out
He's got his yee yees on
He's on
I'm gonna pass. I kind of he's just so he's just cute
Yeah, I like his little shoes. I just want to rob him and just be like go on your way
Like you're gonna steal his shoes. Yeah
I I feel like I'm obligated to smash if you're just gonna take his shoes. I'm gonna take his shoes in the jam on his chest
All right, then it'll it'll be a smash and grab. You smash. Yeah, smash and grab
By the way, we do a smash pass eat and rob
By the way for ours, uh smash passes for these pokemon
So sometimes people decide to eat these like because I would definitely eat him too
He looks like he would taste like ice cream
He looks really sweet like a blueberry taste good like blue raspberry icy
Very I'm also eating him now
That's fair. My cat's food is going off
That's okay. Sorry
Well, they gotta eat they do
I just have to announce it every time so people don't think there's like gunfire in the background
But fireworks are still existent. That's true
Oh, yeah, the fireworks will be on
The 13th for me. So I can't wait to be fighting
In the trenches when that happens
Oh my god
My heart goes out to you
My cats do not have a good time. Um
cypher
Okay, but
He he kind of he kind of hot. I was gonna say smash
Yeah, a little bit of knife play
Yeah, put hold hold those little danger hands up to your throat and go at it
Yeah
If precisely smash
Everyone's everyone's just like, yeah
There's some loud eaters. Can you hear them eating?
I mean kind of jealous. I don't think so
They do much very loudly my cats
Uh jigs
Uh smash
Jeans herself is a queen so I don't
I'll yeah, I don't know she has them perfect if I was a dude
She is perfect blowjob lips
Not only that she's got canonical titties. Yeah, she literally
I wonder what she looks like
Like what's her body type under that like what are her legs look like I wonder
Probably cute, right
Like like maybe like she's a little chubby chubby guy
Little chubby lady. Maybe
And and like not only that like her wig is on point. She is she it's it's there snatch
The lace is laid. Yeah
Yeah, the original this was just a lovely little uh
African uh
No, you're right, but like mr. Popo was like the same way so we can't really be mad at it because we like dragon balls
E
Yeah, mr. Popo never changed nothing
I ain't made mr. Popo purple. Yeah, Mr. Popo stayed black
He was black
I'm not gonna lie. I do love mr. Popo and dragon balls either you bridged. Oh, yeah
I have to watch it again. I don't remember what the
This uh voices were because I remember cracking up. I used to watch that in young justice abridged. Oh my god
Oh, I might recommend watching a sword art online the abridged as well. Oh my god. I'm so watching
Says it made me actually like sword art online because I did not like sword. I don't like sword art online
And this will make you like it. Okay, perfect
Wasn't jinx based on a japanese mountain yokai with black skin and large lips?
Yes, probably a hundred percent because all the pokemon are based off of like yokai
and
animals and animals and just like japanese demons and stuff
And uh mystical creatures so a hundred percent. That's definitely it
But it just it just looks funny
Hahaha
Electabuzz
Do you think he could do that? I think he can I think he can localize his his electrical flow
I just don't like his face
You know what I've always wondered is he like a tiger? I don't know
I generally don't know because I can't like he has like fuzzy arms
But the rest of him isn't fuzzy and I don't think he's a bee. No
Yeah, but he's like
he's like a
Bee dinosaur tiger
I'm I'm still a smash though. Yeah
Because he's got handlebars on his head. He does
Maybe he's got really soft-looking arms like really powerful arms as long as his teeth
Don't nip at me and actually no, you know, never mind. I don't mind a little bit, but you know, I just said for
Scyther
So I I'm not I'm not scared
Um, so yeah, I guess I'll smash
Yeah, definitely a definite smash there. Yeah
He's a mix of an oni and a tiger. Oh
Oh, okay. See that makes sense. That makes sense to me. I get it now. Uh booty cheek head
Pass pass
He's just always gonna have that stupid look on his face
pincer
That's a pass for me. Yeah, I'm I always think of fucking earwigs when I look at a pincer and I hate those bugs
Now if you had said like hair across we are not there yet
But we're
Pincer mega no same thing. No, no
Magmar is good for hot talking. I'm not a dude. So again, I have a penis envy for some of these pokemon
Yeah, so I can't use them in the same way
Uh toros
um
This one's hard. I'd probably die
Because that's just a bull
It is but if I'm a pup I'm a muppet then I could probably take it
Yeah, definitely because like that's how they that's how they breed the cows. Yeah
You know what I'm gonna say smash, you know, I'll I will too. I'm curious. Yeah
Yeah
Take the bull by the horns you got it
Agmar is good for hiding stuff. There's a scene where magmaru hands you a nice toasty pokeball he retrieved from somewhere warm
Oh god, he folded out his ass. Uh magic heart
Smash
Magic heart
Yeah, why?
Okay, so like it's gonna sound really weird, right? Okay, but
First of all, he's really hard and rigid and you can't eat him because they've already confirmed that in the anime
But like he does the only thing he does is splash which means he's gonna be moving
And like his mouth is the perfect size to like latch on to you like one of those said toys. Okay
I feel like with the splash though
It'd be just too much wetness
Like it would be uncomfortable
Nah, it'd be fine. It'd be fine. Definitely would have to lay a tarp down
Well, yeah, but like none of these are gonna be clean. It's pokemon. That's a good point
I'm gonna pass because I wouldn't be able to keep a straight face having that thing latched on to my
Muppet that's part of the experience. You gotta you gotta bully the fish. So he gets the anger so he can become the next one
Because we all know that the next one is what we all want
I'm terrified. No, I'm not
I can't
You really?
I don't know
I mean, it might be too big. I don't think I could handle it
You could take it. You could take it. You can definitely take it. I'll try. I'll take it. I'll smash
Yeah, it garrados is like a smash and even then you don't even have to be on the underside
You could be on top because like he doesn't need anything. Yeah
I'm sure it's like the same logic of salmon spawning where like you like your eggs and he comes and he fertilizes
And you just go on about your business. But this time you're just on the back riding. That's a good point. Okay
This one's too much though. That one's a lot too much
It's very goofy. It looks like they just smack the head onto like a smaller fish
Every time I see this one
It's a pass uh lapras smash smash. Look at that fucking face
She's so pretty
So pretty
The little seductive gays. Are you kidding me?
Easy smash and she she just looks caring. I'll put on a strap for her
Well, she looks at me while I hit it from behind
I'd be under the water for her. I'd take it. Yeah
Yeah, yeah
smash
Yeah
Giganta max I thought there was a cruise ship on her back for a second. Um
That's just a giant version. Yeah, you'll risk it for the biscuit. I can't it's too big
I'll be crushed. My muppet body would be
Destroyed
You know, I I have I have no qualms
Against uh, this this lovely lady letting me be under her flippers. Okay. All right
Moving forward ditto
Smash smash. Obviously ditto is always an obvious smash
Yeah, obviously like ditto can be your wildest dreams or your blandest. Yeah, exactly
Depending on how safe you want to be. Yeah, you can go really vanilla. You can get really dark with it
Ditto's there for you
Yeah, you know, you know, just ditto man ditto
God, now I'm thinking about the pokemon
Movie like the detective pikachu one. We just find out like the guys that have been like with the guy
We're just dittos. Yeah
I
Evie
I'm gonna say pass for evie. Yeah, it's a it's a baby. You gotta get to the evolutions. Yeah
That one's like a fluffy one. It's very cute
Big boy. I want to pet its fluff, but I wouldn't
I wouldn't do that
It looks mischievous too
Like he knows he knows what he's doing
Uh, vaporeon is an obvious smash for me because we all know vaporeon is the most breedable pokemon of all the uh
All the evolutions so of course the most compatible with the human physiology both man and woman. Yeah
So that's a smash
I
Uh jolteon
Honestly, I've never been that fan much of a fan of jolteon
I like jolteon, but not like that. I always thought jolteon was like I I remember I have to have a jolteon on my team
When I would play but not not like that
I would chew on a jolteon toy growing up because it was made out of that good rubber. Ooh
That good rubber that good good
But but it's but it's a pass. Yeah, I'll pass
flaryon
pet smash smash. Yeah
smash
I'm passing on flaryon
That's fine, but like he's so fluffy. He's fluffy. I just pet him
That was a little fluffy boy. It's one of touches little little feets
I feel that but like I I see a personal bed warmer
It's never cold. That's very true, but what if you get too hot?
I can always take the blankets off. Okay
Can we even feel heat as puppets?
Yeah
When we get too hot we're on fire
I look over and look at the poory gone just like here
right after the evolutions
That always cracks me up
So not this poory gone, but definitely the poory gone too
Yeah, yeah, I'm gonna pass on this one
uh
Omenite
That's a smash. It's a smash. I've always thought omenite was really cute. It looks like a little mustachioed man
Right. He's so cute. He's so cute
I love him. I would probably eat him as well
Oh
I remember lord helix. So like were you familiar with twitch plays pokemon like four million years ago?
No
Explain, so what what it was is on twitch. There was a stream
Where twitch chat was playing pokemon one line at a time basically one chat line at a time
Oh my god
They beat the game and like one of them was
A helix because they had the helix fossil
It was it was absolutely amazing. That is pretty sick
Uh almost star
No, I don't like the I'm I like tentacles, but I don't like the beak
I don't like the beak. I don't like the shell the eyes freak me out. Yeah, and I'm I'm okay with that
I'm I'm that's a no. Thank you
Uh
Kabuto
I've never liked him neither have I I also just think of kabuto from naruto. So
There was a guy in naruto named kabuto
Was there or was it something else? I'm pretty sure there was
Hell if I know chat helped
I don't yes. Okay. Thank you. Okay. Thank you
And it's funny because he pushes up his glasses and his eyes look like that
So I always I always think it's funny
Yeah, the white haired guy
I always I thought he was cute
Because I like his little glasses and his glasses would glint
I got you. He's doable from naruto though. Yeah, I agree with that statement. Um
Pass kabutops
That's a smash
Uh
I don't want to be topped by kabutops
Uh, I feel like we would
I just don't think we're compatible
with my with my dom
You know
I don't know. I think he might take a pigging if he was just fim dom him hard enough
You know just girl boss harder. This girl boss harder
Just girl boss harder because like he's basically scyther. Yeah, no wings. No wings. That's that's a good point
Ah
And plus like if you just chain his little like
Scythe sysicles like in front of him then like all he's got to do is move his back back legs
All right, and then yeah, yeah, you have that you have that action pump action going on
Just gonna hog tie up this kabutops this kabutops is getting topped. All right, I'll smash
Yeah
Rip you in half from a hug
aerodactyl
Okay, this one actually pisses me the fuck off. I hate its face so much
I hate him
But like not just because of the way he looks that episode of pokemon pissed me the fuck off
Where ash gets like abducted by the aerodactyl and he tries to tell people. Yeah, that was me and nobody fucking believes him
This motherfucker
Like no one will believe you get abducted by an aerodactyl because look how goofy that thing looks
But then again, like nobody ever believes ash when he when he tries to count his adventures. I think he just gave up
That's very accurate. I think he just yeah
He just is like this came to terms that he's forever a child and no one will ever believe anything he ever says
Like his very first adventure like he can't tell anyone that he was the kid who saved the world because of you two and mew
Felt so fucking bad for him
Like throwing himself into like a pokemon battle
And then like when they meet mew two again, it's like, oh, this is our second time eating
It's like I have no memory of the first time. It's like
Oh my god
Sorry, I didn't mean to go off on a little rant there
No, I love your little rant. It's perfect. I hate aerodactyl. I bet you'll hate aerodactyl mega even more
He looks like a gross dude with a goatee that would like
Have a weird van
and always smell like piss
He looks like that bad dragon from like, uh, what was that movie dragon heart?
Oh
From dragon heart. I hate it. I thought you meant bad dragon and I like like in the toy and I was very confused
Not a bad dragons are okay, but this one is a bad bad dragon. Oh my god
Yeah, the drag I haven't watched dragon heart in a long time. Holy crap. Everybody used to love that movie
Oh, I distinctly watching that distinctly remember my heart is well protected
So pass, uh, snorlax smash smash
smash
You got the nice little
old chubby boy
perfect for snuggling
He is he's so good. He's like you're but he's your lazy fuck. Yeah
Yes
That's literally me
Not eating this one now. I wouldn't eat snorlax
He's like totoro. Yeah. Oh, I want to smash totoro though
I'll smash snorlax
I mean, he's not totoro, but he's like totoro. He's like sexy totoro
Sexy totoro. Yeah, look at his sexy gaze with his eyes half closed
Look, it took this man over like 10 years to stand up. I'm not I'm not gonna say that he's not sexy
Yeah, and I can you can just ride him
And just you know do whatever you want
Of course. Yeah
Yeah, smash. Yeah. Yeah
Uh
That's a tree. Where's his face?
Where's the gigantic max? He's just gone. He's just he's laying down again. He's tired. He got up
When you when you smash the first time and he's like
He's like just do do what you want pick an apple walk walk the bushes
I'll definitely pick an apple. I'm so I'm eat. I guess I'll eat him
You'll eat from him. Yeah, I'll eat the produce of his long eats
I don't know. I feel like it's still a smash. I feel all right to use. I feel like you could use his
Snorlax
his his
What what am I thinking of Snorlax sack as like a beanbag chair sort of situation? No
Like it's sort of a micro
macro sort of situation. Yeah, it's very like giant
Giantess
Yeah, except he
Except he's like the giant. Yeah
And it's more chill
It is definitely a lot more chill and you could take a stroll in his gardens afterwards
Yeah, air air yourself off
Air yourself off. You're just like a wet
Muppet yeah
He just here just like plop as every time you move
It's like just wet fabric as you're going up the sidewalk his treasure trail
Oh my god
I like how he does like have a happy trail technically
See
If he wasn't they knew what they were doing when they designed them
I'm still gonna pass I'm gonna smash
Okay
This is a bird. This is a bird. I'm eating it. I'm eating past the bird pass
However
This one
Like
Don't get me wrong. I'm sure regular articuno is like the equivalent of eating cold fried chicken, which is delicious
But this one this one's more smashable because of like that's just the just the that's the cunty energy that it's the aura
He's serving a very tuxedo mask
I'm gonna yeah, I'll smash I'll smash this bird
Like if it if articuno galer was like a bunny, this is what harlott's final form would probably have
Oh my god, you're so great actually
That would be so true
They do have the same air of it as a harlot
um
Zaptos
Look at those drumsticks good for dipping and mashed potatoes
I'm having that with honey mustard
Eating this. Oh, yeah
Passing and eating passing and eating
Okay, but zaptos galer
Hello
These thickums I still want to eat him. He looks like spicy chicken
I think I'd smash him. Yeah, the the spice would be fun to deal with but probably would hurt a little bit. Yeah
Do you would it be spicy when you copulate?
God, what if it is
I just feel like I would just be burned like that's why it's hard for me
To think that way about fire type pokemon because i'm like I feel like they're just too warm
Sometimes
I think I would burn myself and it's a little cloaca. I'm sure if you use like protection it would be fine
spicy turkey
He gained seasoning um
I'll eat him
All right
Moltres, uh again spicy chicken. I'll eat that
I never liked Moltres. He was always ugly. Yeah, I never liked Moltres either
However
The glare version
He's very pretty very pretty but he kind of looks like a dick
Yeah, like he's got ass hole vibes. Yeah, he's fuck boy energy
He does
I'm gonna pass but he's pretty to look at
He is I I keep him in a gilded cage. Yes
We'll steal him. We're robbing him like his actual self
Yeah
Uh dratini
So
Dratini's are really cute. That's what these are so cute
That's a worm
That's a little guy. It's a little worm guy
I'm gonna pass
I'm passing
Don't you dare leave him alone. We're passing everybody. Relax dragon air
That's a smash. That's a smash
Dragon air has always been a beautiful lady. Oh, yeah, I I remember
being young playing pokemon
And just
Intensely looking at dragon air and wanting a dragon air so bad
Because like not only does it have like three gems that you can touch
Together, right? It's got beautiful winged ears beautiful and it's just long and smooth. Yeah
Everything I feel like it'll be really good for snuggling like you can just like coil up with it
Mm-hmm, and then yeah, I bet like the tail is very prehensile prehensile and it can control it pretty well
So it just like pump in and out
Yeah
Yeah, I'm I'm really feeling dragon air 100 percent always. Yep
Dragonite dragonite. We gotta have words, buddy. I don't
What happened?
What happened man? You had two you you were winning you were winning two. I feel like I got catfish
like
Why why does he turn orange? I never got that
Why is he not like a beautiful blue dragon?
I know it bothers me like a like a nice
almost like almost like Gyarados
type dragon
But a lot smoother and like winged
Like there there should be an alternate reality where dragonite looks more like it's dragon air self
Yeah, like I don't care how they do it put it put dragonite in another like
Like a country like galare and give him an alternate form make him blue
make him
Like beautiful because he deserves to be beautiful instead of a Barney look at motherfucker
I would give him a hug though. I would I would hug him. He's cute, but annoying
pass
Mewtwo
Mewtwo looks like a lush vibrator
Honestly, he do he look like he look like a lush three
Like he's he's strapped in he's ready for you
Oh, that makes a lot of sense
So do you see the comment in the chat?
Oh, which one there's a theory that dragonite and Gyarados got swapped during development
Gyarados would have been dragon airs evolution the blue dragon dragonite would have been magic harps evolution
The color scheme makes sense
Yeah, I don't like it though. Yeah
I don't like it
Love sense looking motherfucker. Yeah, I would smash Mewtwo
I would too
He's skilled with his hands too. Yeah, and he's a psychic type so
Really put my brain to work
Um, it's called a dragonite a Barney look at it
They should have done better. They should have done better all those years ago and we wouldn't have called him a Barney looking motherfucker
Mew or Mewtwo in terms of like power
I'll be
Isn't that Mew? Yeah, Mew
Because Mew is older than Mewtwo. Mewtwo's a baby. Yeah
Mewtwo mega
I always like the design of this but I don't
Like it
Like that I
I don't know. It's a little weird for me. Yeah
Okay pass um mega x
I mean it's just a smaller tail and like more broader shoulders and arms
He looked like he stand on business though. Like he can really plant himself
Really really mating press
Just really get in there. Yeah. Yeah, you know, I'll I'll say
Yeah
I'll smash
You know what?
If I could see him from behind because I'm sure he's got a like a big back porch
I'm gonna say yeah. Yeah, okay
Smash
Um Mew
This is a mouse. You're a smash Mew. Yeah, I'm a smash Mew. Also
Also, I figured Mew was always a cat. That's why it was Mew. Oh, that's a good point
It just looks like a mouse to me Mew is another of all pokemon forms aside
Good point
Besides like
even even though like
Like if we're just talking like pokemon wise the moveset that Mew has
Probably way better than Mew two for smash it. Yeah
I just also the tail the tail looks way more
Like human body anatomy muffin friendly. You're right
So like you just can't
Those little arms. It's also just too cute
Well, I could hug it. I don't need it to hug me
I was like, it's a little paw paws. It's so cute. I can't I like the world something so cute
Mew is a fetus
Ah
Well, if I guess I'm looking at it like a fetus, I guess I'd eat it more than I would
I'd eat a fetus
I mean, it's just under cooked meat
Yeah, that's a good point
Um chikorita
Uh canonical first yandere of the pokemon series
I would eat chikorita
I want animation. I think of someone like cooking a chikorita. I was like that looks delicious
So do you think like it's it's more meat or more vegetable? I feel like
I feel like it has like a meaty core
But like veggie on the outside
I'm gonna pass on eating this thing, but it's definitely not a smash
I'm gonna pass and I'm gonna eat it. I know you don't like vegetables that much
I hate vegetables
Okay, bay leaf is sexy though. I like bay leaf. I like bay leaf's face. I like I like their style
I would smash bay leaf. Yeah, bay leaf is a smash
Chikorita's an impossible burger. Understandable. I would get that meat substitute
The Thickorita video I now I'm tempted to find out what that is. Smash bay leaf
Um
Meganium
It's just essentially almost a feminine
Yeah, I bet it smells nice like yeah, gardenia. Ooh
Smash yeah
Cyndaquil
Oh, that's a pass but a cuddler. Yeah
I want one. I want to get poked
Quilava burned, but like real cute real cute
Quilava looks too sassy to me
Now quilava is a smash for me. Yeah
Yeah, he's in his in his rebellious teenage phase. I know he has a little mohawk going
He's got that anime protagonist. He just needs goggles and a scarf
Maybe like some maybe like some gloves too
So real got yourself a whole OC here. Just need some accessories. That's true. You could turn off the flames. That's a good point
Um, I'll pass
Typhlosion I'd smash
Good
Good good
Good as he is a smash
uh
Typhlosion his he I can't never pronounce that looks a little bit
Predatory in my opinion
It's a smash for me. Yeah, he's got prettier
I need
He's like ladies. Can I buy you a drink? I don't know. He just seems sleazy to me
I'm gonna like he's really nice to look at but I feel like I ended up being disappointed
You know what? I'm okay with him looking sleazy
Because like all all he's got to do is like close his eyes and have like that fox face expression
Okay, like some some uh dojins have and I'm just I'm sold. I'm just here's the bedroom eyes. Very true
All right
Totodile
No, oh no
Totodile is one of my favorite. I would usually
um
I forgot is that heart gold?
I think totodile gold silver. Yeah, uh, I love my heart gold game
I love totodile so much
And that it's evolutions because they were my starter. I can't I could never
I guess totodile has always been a delight. Yeah
Crocodile is ugly to look at though. I hate crocodile
He needs
He needs a little club. He needed a bone club. He needs to pull this together. Yeah
He looks so much like a dinosaur rather than like a crocodile here in my opinion. Yeah
Um, but it's still a pass. Yeah for alligator looks like he's cross-eyed sometimes and he's like screaming
I look I feel like for alligator. I would just ask why are you so loud? Yeah, I feel like he's about to hit the dab
Um
Let it be said the for alligator is a dancer
For alligators, I'm going to chase you down the alley
He's referring to t-pose. Yeah, I just I'm gonna pass the for alligator
uh
centret
Pass
Yeah, I don't know what I could do with that
I mean a hug. Yeah, definitely hug hundred percent hug
But it's a pass. Yeah
Now furret
Furret's too cute for me
Nah, furret's a great up smash because first of all furrets are real fucking big furrets are big
They're pretty giant. I always thought they were small and then I remember looking at the pokedex and seeing how big they actually were
And I was like what the fuck furret seems a vigorous. Mmm
Also, I just love that song
Um, I'll pass on furret you're smashing him. I'm smashing him
Uh hoot hoot
No, that's an owl
I thought with one foot that is a poor baby disabled owl
I remember I used to pronounce it hoot
I mean to be fair though, it's pokemon so that that could be a legitimate american pronunciation
hoot
Oh pass knocked owl
He's so serious very serious. I feel like he'd be such a boring lay
Yeah
And he would just be really judgmental of you after
Yeah, like, you know, you could have done this better or I didn't like how you did that and I'm just like
I didn't even get to come
so
I bet this knocked owl would look at you and be like I can tell the type of poor and you watch is boring
Like like he's into some real freaky stuff and he's always trying to ask you for a little bit more
And you're just like you're a fucking owl. I don't want to do that. And he's like, why are you even here? Yeah
All right pass the knocked owl
ladyba
Hmm, ladyba is so cute
Ladyba is so cute. There's little fist leggies
Looks like he's gonna punch me
But like adorably like it won't hurt. It'll be like a little like like squishy noise like the squeaky squeaky toy noise
Yeah, I think ladyba's like a pass for me. Yeah
Yeah
You're hearing audio cut out
Oh, it's it. Uh, is it me? Is it me my audio coming out?
Tell us
360 degree eye contact though
I mean, that's pretty impressive
Very impressive
Epee. Uh, all right pass ladyba
Okay pass ladyba
Lady in
Okay, I really like lady ins design though. Me too. Like a like a little sentai guy
He really does look like a little sentai guy
All audio, huh?
Well, the stream did like turn into a black screen for me for a moment. So I did it could be my bit rate
Oh, yeah, my bit rate is shit right now
Damn, I just looked at it. I'm getting so many dropped frames
Um, yeah, the stream is lagging. I can see it
Oh
No
I'm not getting ever getting buffering. That's too bad. Yeah, my I literally have like
Normal bit rate, but I have so many dropped frames right now
You know what? It's just youtube trying to nerf us because we're too powerful with these
Definitely, they're just like stop
You can't handle it
enough
Um, it's normal now. It hasn't it's gonna keep doing that. I can tell
I can see it doing it on my oh there it goes now. It's good
We're back
All right, we've never been more back
Uh, I'm passing on lady and just because I just I just want to be his friend
Yeah, like we would go on a picnic
Yeah, 100 and then he would like show me his cool fighting moves
I'd make him a flower crown. That's cute
Okay, spin or act spin or act
I was like it's a like unhappy face on the back on its little butt
Because like I bet I bet he hears nothing but people screaming at him
I'd hang out with him. I take him on a date
I wouldn't do anything though
Yeah, but like I love spiders
I would definitely let him stay in my house and yeah, we locate him to the outside. Yeah, I'll be like you can hang out
You can be a roomie
I'll pass
yeah
And then they just like randomly glow up and they get their roommate that gets a little bit handsomer
And you're just like should I and then you kind of like fight internally with yourself
That's how I would feel about this spider
In
Ariados, yeah
You know
honestly infinite rope
I'm gonna smash their
I was also smashing. I'm also just thinking of like spider riders. Does anybody remember spider riders calling all spider
Riders, that's
I remember spider riders
It never I never found out how it ended
Yeah, I didn't I don't think I ever finished it or didn't it like get canceled
I think it got canceled. Yeah
Stream got smashed
Just for a second. I think it's back up now. Okay
Weird
All right, maybe we'll only last until 10 if my internet's gonna keep being crappy or if you just gonna be gotcha
all right
smash
crowbat
This seems angry
Yeah, I don't want to deal with I don't want to deal whatever anger issues. He's got going on. That's a pass for me
Hmm
Like all he's gonna do is bitch out you in bed same
I believe that too. Oh, yeah, I can see it on my side. How am I stream is buffering
He just reloaded the page. Okay, weird. I'm sorry you guys got kicked out for a little bit
Yeah
Oh, yeah, I could see a lot of people dropped off randomly. That's too bad. Damn you YouTube
Hopefully they find out the stream again. Um, let's get to you
Uh chinchu
This happened to Azura all day
Oh
I think chinchu is so cute. Chinchu is so cute. I couldn't do anything to this little baby
No, no, I couldn't do anything to them. They're too cute. Yeah and lantern lantern just looks like a such a happy person
Little happy pokemon
They're just happy to tell you what they found in the ocean today. Yeah, I found a seashell
And you're just like, yeah, then you kind of just go a little like see adventures with them
Yeah, yeah, I'll be a good friend
Pichu I'm gonna sound really really inhumane, but I'm eating that motherfucker
I'll eat them right alongside you hell. Yeah, we're eating this little mouse
Uh also eating clefa
There's there's no room for argument here. They're both they're both edible. I bet they taste like candy
I know
Pichu's probably like lemon flavor candy clefa bubblegum flavor. Yeah, I was like it looks like bubblegum
I'm chewing on that with bits of chocolate. Yeah
Iggly buff
I almost said ugly buff. I mean, you're not wrong
Also
It's like balls on its head
When they introduced baby pokemon in the second gen they fucked up because these are just food
Yeah, I'm I'm eating this one. I don't get the spiral in the middle of its head. I don't know the lore from that
That's like its baby curl. It's big. Oh, I don't like that
Yeah, it just looks like a Naruto
village sign
Oh, it's from the leaf village
I'm eating it
Jigglypuff's got to get her curl from somewhere. That's her baby hair. That's her baby hair
Uh togapi
Eating eating eating this egg
It's just an egg that sat a little too long. Yeah
Gain sentience
Little too hard boiled, but that's okay. We can fix that. Yeah
I'm trying to think about how I would prepare this togapi
Hmm
You know since it's like technically a hard hard boiled egg
All you have to do is like maybe like stab it and then you can probably just eat it
Yeah, maybe it'll be like a little deviled egg moment
Oh, yeah
Ooh, that'd be pretty good
Like yeah, like you cut off like the top where the three spikes are
Yeah, you scoop out the insides and you make like the inside for devil salad. Mm-hmm
Delicious
When this turn into an eater pass, uh, how we do pokemon smash or pass is we do you'll uh,
Smash or pass them
Or we will also eat them or we'll rob them because some of them have jewels and we want to steal them
Devil's togapi, uh
I can't pronounce that
Oh, that's toga tick. Oh toga tick. I was like, yes togetic
Toga tick
Smash pass eat and rob
Honestly, I'd let I live and let live for this one
Isn't it really big?
No, not quite the next one is though. Okay, because I'm like, can't you like fly on one of them or whatever?
Yeah, it's the last one. Okay. I don't I'm gonna pass on this one
Oh, I forgot the next one comes in the next gen. Yep, that's right actually not to
Eating that it looks like a green apple
Honestly
I I want to pick it up and bounce it because it looks like it has like the same feeling as a tennis ball
I was thinking like a bouncy ball. I would chew on it because then maybe it's like rubbery
Like a chew I want to know if it smells like a tennis ball
Okay sniffing sniffing not we have a new
entry sniff
I definitely would give him a whiff. He looks like he smells like a tennis ball
Uh, is that too?
It's a tennis ball tent
It is a tennis ball tent with a little cat on his on his shirt
Very cute. I feel like he would like open up his wings and flash me
Yeah
Like you think he's
You think he's like skinny underneath the rope
Uh because of the the spacing of his feet. I feel like he's pretty close in the body type
Under the robe like that shape
Hmm
Wait, isn't that wait, isn't that just actually his wings just held in front of him?
So he is just like
That cone shape
I don't know that would mean he's pretty wide. You know what either way it's a pass for me. Yeah
Marie oh
That's a pass but like pass
I love Marie but it's so cute. I might try to eat it
Seal in that gem though. Yeah
tempted to rob the baby. Um
Flappy
Smash smash
Eat. I love I love Flappy
Flappy's been like one of my favorites since gen two. Oh
I guess I love them. They're so I love their design. They're so cute
Ampharos smash
Rob
You know
Smashing look at his little arms
Little flippers. It's so interesting me how the evolution works
um
Because it just turns into like something else entirely
Yeah from a sheet
Like I don't even know what this thing becomes but like I've always thought it was pretty. Yeah, I always like this this lane
It's very
Anka core
Oh see and for his mega I'll smash
Still a smash for me as well. Yeah, I like that's little gem berries in its tail
Belawesome
That's a little lady and and if I had a penis
I would be a smash. Oh 100%
That would think would be destroyed
I'm a I'm a I'm a I'm a lady and I'm polite to the to the belawesome
I don't know. I think I want to corrupt this belawesome. I'm gonna take my strap to her
You know what you do that. I'll sit in the cuck chair for this one. All right
The belussy
I need a picture of muppet me doming a belawesome, please
Uh merrill
Oh man, so for me
I remember when like the magazines came out when we were just about to learn what gen 2 was going to be like
And they were calling merrill peekaboo
Peek a blue that's so funny
Because it's like the first of the pikachu clones, but it's water flavored. Yeah water flavored pikachu
Um, I want to bounce this like a ball
Same
So this is a bounce for me
I'm gonna pass and I would definitely drink water from this. Yes
Same with a zoom merrill
Yeah
That's a body
Suda
Fake ass free fake ass free
Again, I get predator vibes from
It's just a fake ass tree. It's just a fake ass tree. I'm passing on this fake ass tree
I'm also passing
I'm fucking mad
Politoed
That's a cuteie cutie cutie cutie cutie cutie. Oh, I'd carry him around in my pocket
Suda is a flash here
Sudo this Sudo
He talks underage people online for sure. No
He pretends to be something is not
I'd hold a hand with polytone, but I wouldn't smash. Yeah, same
He's just he's got friendzone vibes
Indeed
Hop hip. I'm eating that that looks like a berry
It does look like a berry. I'll I'll give it a taste. It's a pass and a taste. Yeah a pass
Skip loom
I feel like I would that's a sniff for me
Yeah, that is definitely a sniff. I feel like they smell like really nice wildflowers. Yeah
Pass uh
Jumpluffs. Jumpluffs is so cute. It's like, uh, it's a it's a jumpin
I want to blow the little the little
Flippa flops off of it. Same
I guess I would blow then
Yeah, definitely definitely a blow platonically blow
Jumpluff, uh
Safer work version. Yeah
And then I might eat it after I blow it
That sounds weird
A pom
Monkey, I know you're like your monkeys
I do like my monkeys, but a pom's always kind of pissed me off a little bit. All right
And I don't know what it is about a pom. I just a pom doesn't feel like a smash for me
Understandable. I feel like a pom
I just seems like he would just pull some really stupid shit during
And then like as like a prank
And then just like try to laugh about it afterwards
But like it makes me feel really bad or so. I don't know like like he would run up slap your ass
And when you tried to get mad at him, he would be like, it's just a prank bro. It's just a prank. Yeah, I just don't
I'm good
Sunker
Okay, but how can you say no to that face? I love suckers face. It's like
I'm holding it possibly bouncing it
It's going in my pocket. Yeah, definitely
Definitely stuck in the pocket could use it as a plug
But I don't know. I don't want to I don't think I'd use it sexually. Yeah
I'm gonna pass definitely a pass uh sun flora. No
I'm not even gonna sniff that. I feel like if I sniff that I'll be roofy
Yeah, and I wake up
in like a terrible place
And he laces his pedals
and they are
And then he'd be like filling me up with those little leafy arms
Yeah, nah
Yeah, nah pass
Pass uh, yanma
That's a dragonfly
That's a pass for me. I'm squashing that bug
Just kidding. I would never do that because I like dragonflies, but
Whopper
Okay, I can't I can't I can't do anything to whopper except hug it
I am
Snuggling whopper now. I want a whopper plushie
Oh my god
They're so cute
Hello
Uh, I will I'll choose to love whopper
I choose to love and cherish whopper for the rest of my life. All right
If anything were to happen to whopper, I would kill everyone in this room including myself
Same here, um quacksire
I love quacksire. Yeah
Yeah, I do. He's just a goofy guy
He is
I couldn't I couldn't I couldn't hit it though
No, not like a whopper fat. No, like no
I'm passing
Pass peon
Smash smash
We're back to the hot dogs. Yep
Hot hot cat dog
Yeah, let me just look at his butt
Look at that gaze look at that. It knows what it's doing. It knows
She's asking for it
Fox whatever
She's got cheek fluff. She's she's cheeked up. Um
I'm taking my strap to the espion
Smash
Umbreon
Smash smash
Uh, I don't even think this bird would taste good
No, it'd be like two billion expression of eating crow. Yeah, I'm I'm good pass
Slow king
Smash smash
Mm-hmm
Maybe he takes off his hat
Not the hat stays on I don't want him to bump me with it
Well, just don't just don't put your head up there. Okay
How big is slow king
Uh
I think he's like what five feet how tall are we as muppets?
Are we like a foot tall? What are we?
So let's see here. I think slow king slow king's about six foot seven
What?
Yeah
Or I guess he's like
Five foot eleven
Bulbapedia is giving me two different answers. Okay, so average slow king's fucking six feet tall for no reason
um
I might steal a hat
I'm also again wondering how big I am how big are we?
Well, I mean canonical. Well, we're on. Well, if you if you check yourself, you'll see that you're on a hand
I'm looking at my hand size right now. So that means I'm like less than a foot
Yeah, you're probably like about two feet
Because like you got to put your hand into the top. Oh, that's true
Okay, and then like the rest of it's got to be your body. So like
About two feet because like your hand itself is maybe like what six inches
I need a
I need a ruler
I have very long fingers
Now harlots, did you know
If your hand is bigger than your face, you might be a candidate for a cancer screening
Wait, what?
My hand is half bigger than my face and I'm safe. Did you actually put your hand up there?
I did if I know if you were here you would have smacked me in the face. Yes, I would
We need to do an off collab where we do this in person
I just actually get smacked in the face for my stupidity. I realized what that was afterwards. I was like wait, I remember this
All right, I guess I'll smash low king. Yeah
Still a smash for me, baby. No, thanks
That's still a smash for me. I don't like it. This one's only 511 though
I don't like it. I'm passing
smash him
Are we gonna do you want to pause and mistreat us?
Yeah, we're at an even 200
Yeah, and and like after that we get into like the good ones like low punny and all that good
My beloved
All right
I'll pick this up next week. Yeah, I do
We it's gonna be like seven episodes like a hundred an episode or eight episodes. So that's just smashing and passing
Tell me what day you want to do it on and we'll schedule it
Yes
um
Well, thank you for being here trinket. It's always a pleasure to have you
Thank you for bringing me to the sheebie show
That's now called that apparently
um, I hope you guys again, uh
Trinket slash toma made my muppet form. So please
Give her a follow. I'm gonna throw your twitch in the chat
Yep, I stream on toma keys channel. You can find me on the days that say that I'm streaming
On honestly, it's mostly thursdays. I you can see me trinket thursdays tomorrow. It's toma though. Yeah
Just like how I sometimes am shebethany
Uh, let me do an actual
clickable link
Yeah, yeah
Pin this one instead
Heck yeah
Yes, I understand the message was unpanned
I'll pin this one
You know the bots just need you to know
That's that you're just undoing the thing that you said you wanted to do. Yeah
Um, but toma is very cool
She's very talented and sweet as you can see she's a great artist from both of our
muppet forms
Do you want to tell them the good news by the way that you showed me the other day?
the pdf
Oh, I have drawn up
What is a rigable?
uh
shibby cotton bum muppet
That can be live 2d rigged
unfortunately, I'm a little dog water at
rigging so
I might
Need a lot of time to rig it
Or I can find somebody to help
Rig it
DEMPA actually might know how to rig
Mike you could probably ask DEMPA. I just thought of that
Maybe
I just and it's funny because like I just like woke up and she's like look what I made
She just slid me the pdf
And I was just screaming I was so happy
I'll tell you I'll I'll tell you how it how it came to be. I was there the entire uh
Ellen ring stream. Yeah, the entire elden ring stream and I was just working on it
It's it's you guys don't even know
My final form
Slowly coming to fruition
I'm tempted even a surprise. There's even a surprise in the pdf for you. No, I didn't even I didn't want to uh
peek through the files too deeply because I kind of wanted to wait and be surprised until it's rigged
um
Maybe I can also look at some rig videos to see if I can do it myself
I've never even tried rigging before but it's a very good skill to have
It is yeah, and just being able to cut
Stuff as well to make models
Um, I need to learn how to draw properly first. I'm still working on that
You draw plenty. Well, it's really cute your art style. It's developing into something that suits you. Oh, thank you. I try
Oh
But um, yeah, please give uh trinket a follow on tomah keys
We're starting a muppet tuba revolution
We love muppets. We love muppets here
Now I think I want to do a muppet watch a lot at some point
And probably have you on for that. We can watch like muppets in our space or something
Ah man, I was actually just talking about how in the late 2000s
Late 90s early 2000s
There was like just this theme of found family and it started off with gonzo just being like
I'm not sure if i'm a whatever anymore
And then you just the next year after that you come out with the tigger movie and it's like
Man, maybe being the only tigger isn't so based
That's such a good one. There was like a weird
Arrow where there was a lot of found family stuff
Which is also very sweet and cute because everybody deserves family, you know
But like I went back and I watched the trailer for the tigger movie, right?
Do you know how they advertise the tigger movie coming out? No, how did they?
Do you remember first they give you like a really high energy like
Basically the whole high energy song about tigger teaching ru how to do like the soup the the super duper alley uber
Bounce essentially doesn't he like it's raining and it gets really depressing or something
No, they don't show you any context to what happens in the movie. All you know
It's like, oh, it's a little tigger movie. My kids are gonna love this
They don't tell you about the trauma you're about to deliver upon your kids like firsthand
The tigger like runs away because he's like
My family never was coming. Well, I'm going to go find them. Oh my god
Like you don't know that you're in for an emotional bomb
They do the same fucking bullshit with the with the hunt for christopher or the search for christopher robin
Where it's like, oh no christopher robin's gone missing. We've got to go and find him. He's been stolen by
Skull
But it's like and then you have like winnie the pooh just getting all depressed
And everyone just doubting themselves the entire movie and winnie the pooh has like all this cryptic knowledge
That he can't remember because he's a silly old bear
It's the worst
We do not like
Winnie the pooh trauma trauma here whether it wouldn't matter the character
They don't deserve this
They do it to everyone though. The only people who haven't had trauma is perhaps kanga
Kanga hasn't had a single bit of trauma at all. Yeah, kanga's pretty chill
Kiglet's had trauma. I think it's trauma in the animated series
Tigger has a whole fucking movie about it. So does winnie the pooh. Eeyore's just like always depressed
Yeah, Eeyore Eeyore Eeyore never knows a moment's peace because he's always at the beck and call of everybody else
And then like you have made up characters like gopher who's like well study
Ah, i'm just dandy
I feel like yeah kanga is a single mom. That's right because i'm like i can't
I feel like she was like arguing with owl about something
She's a single mom. Yeah
And then owl nothing bad ever happens to owl
Owls in fact he causes all of the problem
Owl causes 90 of the problems because they all go to him because he's the owl and supposedly learned
But owl can't read either
Nope
He's secretly he thinks he's so smart, but he's not
He's not he just uses
The ignorance of the other animals against them
To be some pseudo leader in its sickening
And then they introduce like a half a lump and that doesn't really go anywhere
Half a lump is so cute though
What's his name? It's like ala something
I forget it did like ala wishes. Yeah ala wishes. I love that name ala wishes
It's so cute
And like I feel like if like 2d animation for disney had gone on for a little bit longer
We would have gotten a like a woozel character joining the cast as well
Like a little friendly woozel since we got a really friendly half a lump
Why don't they come up with these names
So owls just Congress I suppose yeah pretty much
I like how he just went on a random tangent
I'm not waiting for the whole character
I'm so sorry. No when it was the both of us and it was so funny
Oh
Okay, well, is there any closing words you want to say to the harem before we
You say goodbye
Brush your teeth wash your butt
And if you ever need that extra clean feeling you can use
Water on your toilet paper and it essentially acts as a wet wipe. Yeah
and then you don't have to you know
Cause issues in your plumbing system by using like
Cotton L wipes or something or baby wipes
Yep, and if you're a little bougie you could put rose water on your toilet paper and then
Or witch hazel which acts as an astringent and it doesn't burn
Very true. Very true. Or you can get a bidet
Or you could get a bidet. I want to try to get a bidet
I don't I couldn't I probably want to be able to install it in my apartment
But it'd be really cool to have a bidet
It would just shoot water up right up my butt
Like like galaga
Oh, no, I don't joker. That's why you double up the toilet paper. Oh, yeah, what you want to yeah
You want to fold that up a couple times before you get you don't want to do like one single square
Yeah, who does that?
I know somebody who does that
What am I friends? I remember sleeping over her house
And she's like, oh, can you grab me a square toilet paper? Like I'm out of toilet. I'm like a square
A square
How do you know a square is not going to keep your hands clean you got to double that shit up exactly
I
I questioned our friendship after that
honestly
Like don't fall for the charnel bears or the shaman bear propaganda
You use as much toilet paper as you want you bought it. I think it was because she grew up mostly in a house full of boys
And for boys like they don't really like when they pee they don't wipe
Or they just like do a little shake
No boys don't wipe. Yeah, they have to do that shake and then you got to wonder like well
What didn't it be effective if they did do like a little dab? Yeah, I think that's she got the dab from that
It's
Yeah, you got a little then you got a little piss stain on your pants, especially if you were in sweatpants
Yeah, and then it just makes like makes it look like you didn't like make it in time. Yeah
And that's kind of sad if you think about it like at least when a girl doesn't make it in time
It's kind of like hell. Yeah
But the smell is there, but we can cover that up too. It's a little perfume bath and potty wars
That's why your kegel exercises are very important to keep you from pissing when you sneeze
Like and it's weird because I didn't
When I was sneezing the uh, I don't is that what you're referencing right now? Yeah, okay. Um
I'm like just I just suddenly feel personally attacked to be funny if you weren't even talking about that
It wasn't because it happened it happens to me too because like when you get older you think
Oh, nothing bad's ever gonna happen to me and then next thing you know
You're sneezing and like lord help you if it happens to be like one of those days of the month
And oh, that's the worst
And then you're like a gusher and then you're just
You're just call. Yeah, call me your little ketchup packet when I sneeze. I swear to god. Um
Um, no, it wasn't even pee
You know
That's fine
That's fine. You know, the body is full of mysterious substances. Yeah
We could basically say that it was sprinkles
sparkles
Rainbows at this point
Like
Like honestly, I'm still trying to figure out if the human body could essentially work like a straw
I wonder
Oh, can you do like
Did you see that like clip of like the girls doing kegel exercises?
And they're pulling up stuff through this. Yeah
I want to try that
I
Would you ever try that
I would but I don't think I could do it. I don't have the pelvic wall string
I'm practicing right now
one
two
two three
three four four hold it
Release
I hope you did it. I hope you did it with us harlot. Yeah, you better
You'll have to go back and you'll have to do it all over again. Exactly
And remember if you're clenching your butt, you're doing it wrong
Um
But yeah, no, yeah guys can do it too. It just makes your your little pee pee bounce
Yeah, and like it's okay because you guys have that button in the backside. Yeah to help
Doesn't it like strengthen their prostate or something?
Yeah, it does. I think also, I don't know if I told you this really interesting fact
What so there there's a scientific method of like
Undoing hiccups
That has been proven and you'll never guess how is it doing
Kegels
No, no, no, it's actually a lot easier than doing kegels. Okay. You just got to put a finger up your butt
What?
Yep, if you put a finger up your butt it helps you stop the hiccups
How
Well, see there's a thing in your in your in your in your rectal space. Okay, I guess kind of push
It's not fake. You can google it. You can google it. It's there are there are there are there are there are findings
scientific finding
This is how I got my friends
Okay, so are you guys saying it's true?
Very interesting
I know lots of stuff
That's how I know
Oh
She does know lots of stuff. I'm being so educated right now
Honestly, it's a mystery what I know. I don't even know what I know until I tell people
It just comes up
I know that happens to me sometimes too just have random facts and I'm just like why did I say
But it's really prevalent
I can't tell you when the war of 1812 took place, but I can tell you that scooby-doo was created on september 1969
That's a more important fact
See it's important to know
1812 a fire call when the war of 1812 took place
Yeah, but when in 1812, I don't know
I
Yeah, you shove your finger up your butt to scare the hiccups away
Because everybody knows the hiccups come from the butt
I'm gonna try that next time I get hiccups
My fingers going up my butt and I'll tell you if guys if it works
Someone else's butt no you don't do that
Could you imagine though if we were on the magic school bus and it taught history instead of science and we went back in time
That would be so cool actually if they had like a magic school bus equivalent for that
Yeah, I like history
How come miss frizzle only taught science actually? Yeah, well they had
So many other subjects you need to learn in school and they were young enough that they only had one teacher
Yeah, she only taught science
Why wasn't she teaching like math or english or
Anything else like we had a music episode, but that was science adjacent. Yeah, they definitely should have taken her teaching license away
Also, I don't think any of these children's parents knew that they were leaving school in the middle of the day and going into like someone's body
Then they like travel into someone's body at one point on the bus
More than once don't they need like a parents permission slip for that?
nah
Don't they need consent to
I mean the child's at school that's consent enough for them to fly a bus into the child, right?
Well, actually no because they flew up. They flew the bus into Ralphie's sick body. Yeah, how can he consent to that? That's not fair
Well, I guess Ralphie said it was okay because he's like you guys are going inside me and miss frizzle's like yep
well
I feel like he felt like he didn't have a choice then
And you know, it's fucked up Ralphie's mom in that episode we find out that her like profession is she's a doctor
What a shitty doctor
So she doesn't
So she's like so like she even sees them inside of Ralphie's body
And she doesn't put two and two together because she's like wow this actually looks like the inside of a body
I can't believe your classmates put this together for you so you can learn how you're sick
Maybe it's a little too much excitement though. We should probably turn this off
Just
Gaslighting her son
Maybe she was gaslighting herself. Oh, yeah, the kid that almost died in space
Yep, that was Arnold. Take Arnold. Yeah, I was an Andrew
And then you had like the narc phoebe
Oh, I hated phoebe
They never did this at my old school. Bitch. You ain't at your old school. And we don't know why
Are you gonna expel because of how annoying you are
Fuck it. Phoebe. Fuck it's Phoebe, man. Carlos
Carlton is terrible puns
And then you had Tim who could draw
That was his that was this thing that was this thing
Yep, and then you had Keisha who was a good journalist. She was pretty good
I thought Keisha was cool
Yeah, Keisha was real cool. Arnold's now wanda. I wanted to wanda wanda fighting the fighting the curb in 4k
Every other episode they killed Arnold's cousin
wait
They killed janet
I hated janet
Janet was real annoying
Arnold's cousin almost rat the class out to the police and then they killed her was
I believe it too. I kind of want that to be canon
And then of course you have dorthian girl with two names bit of a no at all. Yeah
What a what a what a ride that show was I know
I wish I could be on the magic school bus. Yeah despite everything I wish I could be there too
I think
I'm trying to think of like what our character types would be
Hmm. Well, it is a short bus. So that's money
I'll be the really dumb blonde that doesn't understand what's going on
I'll be the one that thinks of way too many things that don't
pertain to the moment
You're just like they're like in his body and you're just like did you know that plants and they're like shut up trick
Ah, you just say the most inopportune facts at the wrong time
Did you know more people die because they wear their seatbelts?
Everybody on the bus just takes off their seatbelt seatbelts everyone and then you just say that
Horror theory is interesting on the magic school bus. Is there a creepypasta of that? I bet there is
Look, there's so many
Like I think like around last year
I stumbled upon the tiktok series where they were
Introducing like the magic school bus as a horror based theme and like
Every every field trip somebody would die, but they would be reincarnated by the end of the adventure. Oh my gosh
That is to miss frizzle just like some sort of crazy witch
Honestly, okay. So talking about I'm so sorry
Can I can I tell you about mary poppins? Yes, you could tell me about mary poppins
Okay, so you know how I also love mary poppins and you are aware that they came up with a mary poppins to mary poppins returns, right?
Yes, I remember watching that with my mom
Okay, mary poppins 2
Pisses me off right because it is seen for seen original mary poppins except now mary poppins
Now that she has like CGI magic instead of like practical effect magic feels more like a demon
Who's come back to feel some contractual agreement that she has with the bank's children
That
That actually makes so much sense
Because there's that scene like towards the end of the movie where we're already past like the point of hype
And they're like, oh no, we have to get up to the top of big Ben to stall time
And so you see all these lamp lighters making their way on the BMX bikes
Ladder to shit climbing on the outside of big Ben and mary poppins is standing there cool as a cucumber
And like she finally gets fed up like never seen humans to do a woman. She's not human
She's a demon
At that point and then she flies up with her umbrella
You see her silhouette and I'm like, bitch you could have done that the whole time and save these people like death because I'm pretty sure
Almost five of them fell off the tower that is big Ben
That would make a lot of sense because then as a demon she would just
Like to see humans suffer from time to time
And she does see humans suffer
She actively does see them suffer and then she likes to punish them especially when they're kids
and kind of like
Because think about like the medicine they didn't want to eat the medicine. She kind of like tortures them even
Yeah, because like you can even tell that she's not really there for the children to learn a lesson
No, the actual children. No, she's there for michael and jane because jane's almost like a spinster
She's like, I don't really want to date anyone mary poppins mary poppins sets her up with lynn manwell maranda
And then out of everybody, you know, that's your torture. No
And then like for michael, she's like you need to get over your dead wife. You have children my guy
i'ma help you
understand this
That you need to be the adult and they need to not be the adult
Well, what what would be what would be the the narrative with the chimney sweep?
So the chimney sweep is lynn manwell maranda is taking on the role of burt
In this movie, but what about like normal burt?
normal burt
What would be the
the story between them that he like
Fallen was she like a succubus?
so the way that I see it right
Is in the very first mary poppins movie
mary poppins has been to london before and she's known burt since she was like a younger sort of demon slash witch
And they sort of have like this sort of coexistence things because burt's got a little tricky magic of his own
True, but he can't really do it because he's not really a fully
Realized or or a wizard of some bro. I imagine they do like sabrina the teenage witch like they do with netflix
Except they do mary poppins and they make like a darker mary poppins when she was younger
You know what this disney's missing out because I have a million great ideas
They need to hire you. This is brilliant
I love that so much
Pennywise feeds on fear poppins feeds on joy
I don't even you know what I don't even think poppins feeds on joy
She feeds on what is considered obedience
Essentially obedience turning people into societal members and also teaching good family values
Because it takes place in britain even though they don't have british accents
Yeah, good point
Because like mary poppins could care less about women's suffrage in the first movie. Yeah, good
Yeah, she was just like whatever
Whatever, I don't I don't need to vote human laws don't really affect me. Yeah, she's like I've seen centuries of this
It all it all turns out the same
Hmm
Women go on having children men go to work and they neglect their kids. I'm here to teach you. Don't neglect your kids. Yep
I like this theory. This sounds very legit
Sorry, we went we went we went on a weird sort of roundabout from winnie the pooh
To magic school bus to mary poppins
Mm-hmm
We should just I like how we just have like lengthy discussions about
children's movies and shows and how they
See just conspiracy stream about how they're secretly all twisted
Analyze them
I'm a bit of a conspiracy theorist
I like it though. Are we all we should we should they're all we should all should uh, you know
Humor a little bit of conspiracy every now and then a little bit. Sometimes it's the truth
Yeah, like did you guys know that there's a genre of music that's devoted to flat earth?
What?
Yeah, what's it called listing is it good flat earth. It's honestly flat earth got some bops to it. Okay
all right
Trinket 15 minute rambles are impressive. This is why we're good friends because we're both just yappers
She's the only one that can match my yap
I can yapp as long as someone yaps with me
Flatcore oh my god, I mean they're bops
Oh, Mary and peter pan are the same
What explain elaborate on the peter pan theory
Oh, okay. I see what they're going for so peter pan himself is a bit of a demon because he goes and he kidnaps children from open windows
True
Because he he gives them this lie
You can come with me and never grow up, but that's not necessarily true for children that go with him
Because they do eventually grow up and when they grow up in neverland they turn into pirates in which peter pan kills pirates
And he's just constantly feeding himself
Whatever sick twisted
Joy he gets out of killing pirates
Oh my god
And then here's here's another good one for you when he's actually going to uh the the window of the darlings where windy
john
and
Windy john and never got the other one
I forget him too. Anyways, michael there it is. Yeah michael
So when when he goes to that window, he's been there a few times because he loves listening to windy tales stories
But there's not an opportunity for him to kind of slip in and steal the children because they're perfectly happy
They have no reason to run away from home
Yep, until like that night when the father's fed up because a dog shouldn't be a nanny that don't don't let anyone ever tell you otherwise
I would make a great nanny. I am a dog. She would be a great nanny. I will watch I will watch your children for you
Yeah, and then I'll take a nap. Yep
So anyways, peter pan sneaks into the house, right? Yeah
Yeah, yeah, yeah because because his shadow gets away from him anyways
So that's like the reason why he goes in. Yeah
Yeah, so he goes in wendy's like, oh my god. There's a boy in my room
Peter pans like
Well, yeah, but i'm here for my shadow. Oh
well
I can help you stick it back because he was trying to stick his shadow back on with soap at first because you know soap's kind of sticky
So yeah, a little bit sticky. It's not that smart. He's not that smart because it also can be slippery
Yeah, and so she's like, I'll just sew it on for you
And of course wendy's getting fresh because she's about to hit that puberty streak and she's like
I'll give you a kiss and he's like, okay
And she and he's like hold out his hand. She gives him a thimble, of course, and you know, but
Then she's like, okay, then I'll give you a thimble and she's she's about the plant one on him
Of course and then tinker bell a little the little demon that that stole peter pan away. She is fey. She is fey
He is fey. So is peter pan a changeling?
Peter pan would be a changeling because he was human and then he was
Abducted by fairies because he ran away from his parents when he was still a baby
Because they were they were talking his future way too early above him. Yeah, like that's how you give a baby anxiety
Oh, we'll visit the finest schools
Yardsdale
Princeton and he'll join his father in the courts and it's like, ah, he just couldn't handle that
Yeah, so
He goes to neverland. He grows up there. He develops his own sort of magic because yeah, peter pan doesn't need
Yeah, peter pan doesn't need fairy dust
To like fly he makes his own now because he's imbued with magic
Yeah, because he's been there for so long since like right only happens when you're young. I bet
Huh, that's really interesting then because like why didn't
some of the kids
get the same
ability as him
Because they're always changing out because they always grow up
What stops him from growing up?
well
Because he was the first
He and neverland are kind of tied together now neverland's attached to him. He's attached to neverland
That's why whenever he leaves neverland if it's frozen over. It's cold. It's dead
And then when he returns the sun is back. It's warm. It's summer. You do fun stuff
I can't live without him and he can't live without neverland
Right
Fascinating
So anyway peter pan is in the same
Like breath like mary poppins in that he
He doesn't really help children, but he steals children. Yeah, he's an entity that just does things on us on win
right and mary poppins is like
The one who comes to you for when she needs to eat
mm
Whereas with nanny mcfee nanny mcfee is just selfish
I used to love nanny mcfee that movie was so I love that movie
I love nanny mcfee nanny mcfee is
Like the saw the opposite side of mary poppins. Yes, just like more
hardcore
She she's like she's like when mary poppins fails to get the job done. She's the boot camp of equivalent of mary
Yeah
but she's not like
I wouldn't say she's a demon
No, she's not I would say just she's like a witch
Yeah, she's like a cursed hag. Yeah just gets off on like the more you hate me the longer I'll stay
Yeah, but when you want me I'll go away
It's like damn. Okay
Yeah, it's like it's and that's how you know
Because that's how witches are like a riddly like that
Yeah, yeah
Peter Pan is an s of scp
Yeah, I don't remember a lot of the nanny mcfee movie the second one
I don't remember the second one either, but I feel like it's not attached to the first one really
Oh, wait, really
It's a really good point. No, I'm going back to Peter Pan
Neverland takes the time from the children that he brings and gives it to Peter Pan
That would make a million dollars worth of cents. Mm-hmm. He's stealing time from them
Boy Robin Williams version
Oh, I do love the Robin Williams version. Yeah, where he goes back like because like even in the storybook like the original
M.M. Berry Peter Pan storybook, which by the way fun fact about Peter Pan
It is not actually public domain
Any money that you make off of Peter Pan should go to the children's hospital because the rights are owned by a children's hospital
That's really cool
But a lot of people don't listen and do that. So, you know, it's kind of a hand wash at this point
but
I digress
I digress uh my point being
So with Peter Pan. Mm-hmm
Wait, hold on. What was I saying?
Oh, hook. Yeah, we were talking about hook
So it's really interesting because Peter Pan actually in the book
Takes Wendy's daughter Jane with her kind of like how
When Disney made Return to Neverland the sequel that does introduce you to the fact that
Wendy grows up and has a daughter named Jane. Yeah, you know in a son
and so he actually does take Jane to
Like Neverland and she becomes the very first quote-unquote lost girl
But when hook happens we we pass over Jane and we meet Moira
Who is
Wendy's great granddaughter and Peter is just so enamored with love
He's like, I don't want to go back because he now has something
to stay for
It's kind of weird he just like goes after one daughter after the other
Well, because he wants to keep the bloodline coming to Neverland because they're great storytellers apparently
Yeah, but like when he when he finds that one and it gets like I I love using this the zing
the zing
You know the hotel Transylvania zing
Um, he's just like, yeah, no, I'm staying and then of course in in the hook timeline. It just goes all awry
Hmm
Now I will say my favorite rendition of peter pan is the live action peter pan that came out in like 2000
With that one boy jeremy with the focus aim is
Yeah, and the hot in the hot rendition of yeah
Yes, I like had this really weird like
Romantic subplot between captain hook and wendy where captain hook was kind of oh wait. Do you mean the more recent one?
Um, no not pan because pan was dog stockwater. I didn't even watch that one
I have to it was it. Yeah, it's one of jeremy's something. Um, it would have been peter pan from 2003
Yes, yes. Oh, yeah, wait. Oh, yeah, jason eyes explain captain hook
And he was hot. Yeah, that's so true
And like honestly if if I were to put together like a peter pan watch along
I would show that peter pan from 2003 followed by hook
So true because that would be the best way to watch it because you kind of get like this nice fun story where it's like
Oh, okay, you get a really
Book accurate peter pan and then you get like fan fiction that is hook
Sorry, I'm staring at pictures of the movie because I'm like my memory is being jogged
I'm like, wow
I love that. I do believe mr.
Mr. Smee was always played by
Yes, me
Let's see. Mr. Smee was always played by um, um, um
Uh, oh man. The name is the main the name is uh escaping me. I have no idea
Uh, he was he was eddie valiant in who frank roger rabbit. Oh
You're right. Oh my god
It's just
He he plays a really good schnee. He does. You're not that's so and mario. You're right. Oh my god
He's also mario on the live action mario the first one
Oh, that one was so goofy drunk off his drunk off his ass. Yeah, essentially
But I don't think he placed me in the 2003 peter pan. I think he's gone by then. Yeah, I don't think he did. Um
Peter being the grim reaper neverland is the afterlife in a shadow was a demon following him
Interesting theory
Oh, uh to answer miss morgan, I've seen twisted the musical but miss shabby doesn't like musical
I don't like musicals
Yes, please do tell me
Okay, so twisted is basically like a retelling of a laden, but it focuses on jafar more than it does a laden
Really, it's actually a very good musical. I highly recommend it and I know you hate musicals
I know you do but
It's star kid musicals are a are a are a fish of a different color
Like they are rainbow fish to me. Well, explain the plot to me
Okay elaborate further
so if you can't imagine
twisted takes place towards the beginning of
a laden essentially
But instead of jafar like being an asshole like he is in the original movie jafar is actually this well meaning
royal vizier who just wants to do
Good things for the kingdom, but everyone thinks that everything is his fault because he is the royal vizier
But he's taking up the mantle after a bunch of corrupt royal viziers who only believe in the golden rule that is
get paid
whereas jafar uh
Is more on the side of do unto others as you would have them do unto you. Okay interesting
Everyone is a is a bastardization of themselves including the princess who doesn't have a name. She just goes by princess. That's funny
You have captain of the guard who's really funny. He has
Um, you have a laden who is a 32 year old man
Who they make him really creepy and he just he's an asshole. He steals everything. Oh, I need to I need to look up pictures of
Yes
And honestly the acting is really good. I would love to just sit down and watch this with you
And you also find out the jafar had a loving wife who he loved
Based off of charizard. You know the uh story teller of a thousand and one
night
Sorry, I'm looking at the cast pictures and this is goofy. Wait, is this supposed is this right by the same person who wrote wicked?
Not wicked. No because it looks they have the same exact
like
Cover it's sort of a it's sort of a play on wicked whereas wicked. I do like wicked
I did watch wicked wicked. It's like the only musical way
And lion king was very good
Uh, then I think you would absolutely adore
Twisted all right. I might have we might have to watch that together then
Yes, and it's on youtube like the whole thing. Oh sick. Okay, perfect because star kid always puts their musicals on youtube
All right
I might be able to stomach a musical because the plot is very intriguing and again. I do like cool twists on
Already told stories like that. So I really liked wicked for the reason. I can't wait for the wicked movie to come out
also a really good thing about uh
About twisted is you know how in Aladdin like the movie Aladdin like the cartoon
there's like that prince who's like a throwaway gag where he goes to meet the princess and
Jasmine sticks her tiger upon him and yeah, and all you remember is like he has funny boxers and he's just storming back to
Oh, yeah, because it frips his pants off. Yeah
He actually is a character a likeable character with a likeable song
They give him a whole like it's so funny when like sometimes uh spin-offs like elaborate
Unusually like throw away at like NPC like characters
It's then they give him some backstory. I love that
Oh my god
He's a huge plot point and twisted. I don't know so many of you guys like musicals
I
Love musicals. Oh my my my audience likes musicals too. Apparently. I'm very surprised
I can I can introduce you to some that you might actually like
Oh like
I don't know if I don't know if you've ever given it a try but uh, I'll give Roger and
Roger and Hammerstein Cinderella with brandy and Whitney Houston's pretty good. Oh
Don't even get me. I had that movie on
I loved that movie
I love brandy cinderella
Oh my god
Of course, I'm a I'm a black girl. How could I not like this?
So good
Oh my god, I forgot that that was technically a musical
I think I didn't mind them as much when I was a kid now. I'm just like I'm irritated
I had I had I had my boss described to her co to her grandson because we went to go see wonka during christmas
That a musical is just a movie where the dialogue turns cursive sometimes the dialogue turns cursive
Okay, I have seen descendants. I won't lie. I have watched
I think two of the descendants movies
I know that a christian chenna with is in one and she's got a bomb musical number that I really like
I think there's a third one
I know that they're coming out with an alice in wonderland one, but I've never seen them
interesting
Mm-hmm. I've also never actually watched high school musical because it was so advertised so heavily
I was just like I ain't watching this. I liked high school musical. Okay. Maybe I did like musicals
I was like, uh, and I said I didn't watch a lot of musicals. Oh, yeah. I know I liked high school musical
I pretended to hate it
But I secretly liked it
I really like get your head in the game
I remember trying to do the and that and we're all in this together the choreography. Oh
I hate myself for that
My only my only regret is I got on the glee train too late
I don't like glee though. I tried watching glee my parents liked glee a lot
I don't blame you for not liking glee though because it's like digrassy
Yeah
That's a good grassy hilarious
I don't I haven't watched a grassy in the longest time
I I'm wondering how it aged
You should do you should do a watch along the watch along the grassy watch and this drake in a wheelchair just hanging out
um, I mean, I'd rather watch misfits
or freaks and geeks
um
I don't
Have you ever seen freaks and geeks freaks and geeks?
No, I don't think I've ever seen freaks
You would love freaks and geeks son. Oh my god. I think probably with seth rogan and
His friend that always does james franco
I think
Maybe I might like it because I did like uh, the whitest kids, you know
You would okay. You definitely like it. You definitely will either it's like it's so goofy
We love goofy and then you also have um, oh, what's her name?
I always forget her name
Her funny name goofy is canonically the only disney character that has had sex. I yeah, he
Goofy gets it
Yeah, he can he can get it. Yes
I forget like he's got a son. Yeah
Oh, wait, I'm sorry. I misspoke pete also has had relations more than relations
Well, yeah, he has a smoking hot wife named peg
True
That's right. Actually a beautiful daughter. He has two children. All right, so I guess only the dogs can reproduce in this
Well pizza cat
Pizza cat
Yeah pizza cat
What?
Yep, he has pistol. He has peg. He has pj
Egg like pete it's a cat. That's why he hates mickey mouse so much, but he's super chill with goofy
My life is a lie
I had no idea. I thought he was just a short-eared dog
Not either cat
Pistol pete is the youngest daughter of pete and peg that appeared in goof troop
Mm-hmm
It's funny because
In the series max is 11 and a half years old moves his father and their cat waffles
So it's like they own a cat and there's cat people
Well, to be fair pete had a dog and it was like a real bougie dog
Oh, I remember this from goof troop. Yeah
His voice by Nancy Cartwright. Oh, yeah, who boys Bart Simpson
Yep, she's been in the industry a lot. Yeah
I've been watching um game grumps play like the putt putt and she voiced in some of the
the
Super ever going it's called
Whatever company that made those games
Super humongous. Yeah
Yeah, I'm just like man. I never played any of these games. I kind of wish I did
My favorite putt putt is putt putt saves the zoo. Putt putt saves the zoo. I remember watching them play that
It's pretty goofy. Um
Yeah, I think I think it was before my time
the putt putt games
I think they're on sale on the steam sale now. That'll be funny to play
I I kind of want to play pajama sam though
Pajama sam. Oh, yeah, I watched game of play pajama sam
Or that was that was good too
there's like really cute point and click adventures and
I think actually maybe I'll recommend mercy to play one of those because mercy has gets motion sick
And so I think she would probably appreciate kind of a cutesy goofy
point click
Maybe she's already played one
Maybe or she might like monkey island
What's monkey island?
Monkey island is like a pirate
adventure sort of like point and click adventure
But I don't know too much about it
But I but people are always recommending to play it
Maybe if she played that because then she would can wear her little eye patch and then she can cosplay as a little pirate
Yeah, yeah
She usually cosplays as the characters in the games that she plays like she was mario the other day and now we call her mercy
Oh, it was very funny
By madame you're 56. That's true. So it was it was after my time actually
This the super humongous games
Oh
All right, P. But now you can play them with your computer. Yeah
I was too poor as a child to afford them before
back when I was
Born in 19 fort. That's not
I don't know. I can't I can't really math. So like can I
I like how misdreavus is just in between us this entire time during this conversation
I know just like minding her own business. She's in her own lane. Yeah. She's hanging out
Oh
All right
That was a good tangent for 40 minutes
My dad
No, please don't ever don't ever apologize. Literally. I I told you I was streaming till like 4 a.m. Yes
today technically
Because I was just going on tangents just talking about absolutely nothing
Oh my god, this is great. I also just like getting lore like
TV lore from you and cartoon lore
Man, I I can go off on like any sort of cartoon without trying
My favorite though has been like pebble and the penguin
But I won't get you started because we'll be here for two hours. Did she just start watching that?
I I watch it every week
Sorry, I like it's funny watching my muppet bounce
Also, my favorite thing to say right now is rest in peace martin short
Is he dead? Yeah, I'm like, no, he's dead
No, he's not dead, but it's past his bedtime and I'm hope he's sleeping. Well
I hope if you're sleeping well
I hope you're sleeping. Well, mr. Martin short. I love you
Uh great comedian him and uh, I love him and
What's his face?
They're always it together in something
Oh my god, I'm gonna they're literally in no murder no murders in the building together
Uh
It can't be Andy dick everybody. No, it's not any dick
Everybody hates Andy dick. Oh my god. I'm gonna I'm just gonna look up
Because I I like martin short, I even liked him in that
Steve martin. Thank you
Steve martin so funny
Yes, I liked I liked martin short in that terrible dorthy returns movie. That was like basically
The producer's live action in real life
If you don't know what the producers is about
Which is a musical by the way, but it was like a movie that is called a musical before it was a musical
it's basically about like
Uh an accountant and a producer getting together and the accountant's like hey your books are wrong and the producer's like look man
I'm on hard times. Can't you just move a few decimals and then the accountant's like, you know,
You know, you could make more money with a flop than with a hit
Because if you make a flop, you don't have to pay back what you spent on the flop
Which is like what a lot of a lot of uh hollywood companies do
Right now where if they considered like a form of media a flop, they'll write it off for taxes and they can't like
Make that's so stupid
It is it's how we get a lot of lost media and I hate it. Damn
Damn them
Someone's asking where your clothes are at
I'm a dog
I'm wearing a collar. That's my clothes. Yeah
She's clothes. She's wearing her collar
Let's think about me where your clothes at
I'm like the dog like walks into a room
Oh
Like you don't go around looking at like family guy wondering like man. Why isn't brian wearing a shirt? That's a good point
I'm only wearing clothes because my bunny boobies are very large
And that's I just don't think it's the proper thing to do
Obviously, you're very talented. That's why you have clothes. Yeah, although I wonder if I took my bra off
Would I just have velvet?
Hmm
You know, I imagine maybe I had considered giving you a muppet nipples, but we didn't do it
Yeah, the other art you gave me muppet nipples
Well, yeah, but that was for a comedy. Yeah
So, I mean I'm
Because you don't have any nipples. That means I don't have any nipples. We're just nipple monopolist
Like if I had like legs like if you sewed me up and you like made me like a full body muppet
I probably have I probably have mupples
Yeah, I kind of lower down on your belly. Yeah
Yeah, like especially in this form, but who knows who knows if it's between like two
Four and six who knows we'll roll a dice when we get there
roll for mupples
Roll for mupples one d6
No muppet milk. Uh, sorry. No, I don't think
I don't have organs
We yeah, we don't have well you could pour milk on us and suck it out like
Like a security blanket sort of thing. Yeah
Like use my little muppet
Booby is a security blanket
Yeah, I was a little passy
Yeah, just pour a little milk on her and then just suck it out. Yeah, see that works
Yeah, it's kind of like what people do with their hoodie strings like delicious
Honestly hoodie strings are quite delicious. I will honey, especially when their agla is just like just right
Oh, I know what you're talking about and I 100% agree and like chewing on that
And and like getting the knot undone and then redoing it later. Hmm
They don't get it. This is why we're on the short bus and uh, the magic school bus
We don't understand the science and miss frizzle just keeps us there. Yeah
Okay, they don't have organs we can go as deep as we want without worry of wrecking you can still rip us
Well, yeah, but we could be sewn back up. Yeah, we could be sewn back up
So I guess like as long as we're forever it immortal in the muppet form
It it could get as violent as possible. But like cleaning ourselves would be kind of frustrating
Do you think they would just throw us in the washing machine?
No, we don't need to breathe. So I think that would work out
Yeah, but I'm gonna request goggles and
Because I can't see underwater neither can I I didn't know that people can normally see underwater
I didn't know that either. It's it makes my eyes all stingy. I know it hurts my eyes real bad even if it's in like a normal clear
Water thing. I thought nobody could see underwater
Same
Apparently, it just means I'm blind
Do you also hate getting water up your nose? Yes, it burns. I I hate water on my nose
So bad
Like you take a washcloth and you dip it in like the shower water and then you wipe your face
You don't go like full face into the water. No, exactly
I get you. I'm good on that
Or like I like plug my nose
Plug your nose close your eyes and just a quick
And then that you're out. Yeah, just like what's that? I saw that animation
Oh, wait, it's yeah, what's when the dwarves from snow white are washing their face
God that meant that that scene makes me
Irrationally angry. Why?
Because I would try to do it and that's how I learned that I hate what getting water up my nose
You do grab a dub is up and
And and then the fact that oh man, I'm going to go off on another tangent grumpy was absolutely right the clocks
Though white as a fucking trifle
Because
Like I don't blame grumpy for being a woman hater. She brought a lot of trouble. Yeah
They were just chilling and she did just like barge on right in do everything
And she brought a witch
Like if somebody came into my personal space and cleaned up everything my organized chaos
I'd be so upset
And then like you hear the distress. It's like
Somebody washed my cup sugar is gone. It takes time to develop a sugar crust
It takes time that bitch cleaned his cup
And you know, she probably didn't clean it properly. She had the animals do it and they probably licked that
Oh, yeah, it's all it's not even properly cleaned. It's it's even technically dirtier than when she they how they left it
Oh
gross
And then she had the nerve to shame them. It's like did you wash your hands before supper?
Bitch, you're in their house. How are you gonna make the man? I know she just comes in all high and mighty
Like princesses, man. She wasn't I am I am
I have come up with the opinion that snow white is not just a movie about a princess who's evil stepmother
Like once her dead it is about two doms in a kingdom fighting for supremacy
Because so light is a developing dom
And she's those little men
Yes, the queen is a developed dom and she doms the kingdom. Yeah, she does this for beauty and her power
But like at the same time she's like, oh no an up-and-coming bitch and that up-and-coming bitch is using her powers
Yeah
Unbeknownst to anybody to get things done the way she wants. She domps the forest. Oh my god
She doms the little men
And she basically doms the heart of the prince who's just kind of waltzes into her. I know he just like shows up
That's kind of weird
When she's singing and he just shows up. They're all weird
I think the queen is the only in the dwarf is the only rational ones here
right
damn
But yeah, that's how I fell about snow white
Hahaha
Snow white being a soft dom actually makes sense and she's around 14. Oh, I forgot how young she was
It's just she be no. No. No. I'm not snow white
I'm not snow white either
I was about to start singing wishing well
I'm wishing
For the one I love
I thought we're gonna do it for a moment. Oh, yeah, but it's always to find me
to find
Today
Now that I found you here's what I have to say
Hey
And then he just goes in for it and she's like, oh my god, damn just like that
Jesus oh my god, I think I got the vapors the vapors
Oh
No, she'd be just Jessica Ravis says has to help her out the laundry she
Uh goes from soft on snow white and everything to mean like yeah, so I think about snow white so casually
okay, yes, but um
in short
If you do use our Muppet bodies for your gooning purposes
You have to make sure that you either align us with something
Or clean us properly because that just isn't fair to us, you know
Right, don't just throw a rag at us and call it a day
You know, we're not proper aftercare. Yeah, don't use us as a rag
Oh, no, I just realized I never told you my ratatouille theories
And we'll save that for the next episode
Next time on tracking balls
All right, I'm gonna go to bed
You'll have to you guys will have to find out in the next episode of smash your pass
We'll figure out a time. Let's slap it on my schedule next week. Um, but good night
Good night everybody
Good night. Good night. Harlotte. Have a good one. Oh my god. I hope you guys enjoyed our
Silly appage today. I know I did always fun. I always enjoy talking with you
Yeah, always fun to have Trinket on and I'll just spend time with her in our an hour muppets together
We're too powerful
too
We could yap for hours and be actual yapping
All right, bye guys
Bye, don't forget to take a shower tonight. Yep, brush your teeth
Wipe your butt
Put a little water on it
And don't do that single paper bowls yet. Don't do it. Don't do it. You stinky
stinky hero
You